we
we are live says youtube there's a three
five six seven eight counter
yes indeed
here we are are we actually live yet oh
my god i think we might actually be live
should do it
i do what i can
at all times it's morbid time it's
always morbid time kieran shaw
kieran shaw auntie
just says jaby kawaii
mikrios
andre taylor pablo the pigeon you guys
know what to do let us know if we're
live let us know what the sound sounds
like let us know if the sound is is
terrible this is john's first birthday
live stream people i know so there's a
lot of pressure there's a lot of
pressure for john to deliver on this
life i gotta not die during the
livestream
okay yeah we're live i see it on our
phone
hooray it's happening it looks and
sounds all right
not bad all right john take it away
master ryan cross
zachary de jardin
eduardo ortega fool's gold giga supreme
there are too many of you guys to name
but thank you all for showing up to mike
look at all these people showing up for
you john no people show you very kind
and here you are telling me every day no
one loves me that's right the world
hates me the world wants to bring me
down are you replacing me with koi
every day i mean you know koi is a is if
anybody replaced me i wouldn't be sad if
it was coy i mean i would be sad but i
would be like yeah yeah i get it i can
see you and koi booting me out of the
company that's the goal
off the board we're like the real
rejects needs to be a whiter
organization john read some happy
birthdays god damn it pop culture i'm a
little quiet
how's it going oh i'll turn you off i
have greg and my left ear is enjoying
this very much
that's one of those oh are we are we are
we uh mono sided i think so yeah all
right don't worry we're gonna fix this
this wouldn't be a real rejects live
stream if this wasn't messed up yes of
course not of course not
stream track
you got this john here i'll read some
i'll temporarily read your comments we
are down mixing to mono john is [ __ ]
45 i thought the man was 30. he's 45
years old 65 years old born in 1977
yes did i do math correctly
1965.
1977. john do you like kung fu panda i
do skadoosh i am a fan yeah it's john's
45th birthday people yeah i am too old
for this [ __ ] now's your chance ladies
all the ladies in the in the rejects
nation who think john's super sexy
start letting him know sound off in the
comments start letting the man you know
inflate my ego please
uh yes and and now you should also you
should be hearing us both equally in
both your ears now i downgraded to uh
mono so we're good guys slow down
i don't know we don't we don't slow down
ever oh thanks 850 films 850 film says
we hate you so much
john i appreciate the honesty that's
what i want today there's no way he's
older than greg by a lot oh yeah greg's
only 26. yeah by 20 by 19 years john is
uh john is much older than me yeah by 19
years
he was grooming me pulled the nezra
miller
i'm basically ezra miller guys
which uh i'll be replacing flash pretty
soon it's gonna be good it's gonna be
good
if i'd if i
if i hadn't anticipated a different
video i would have uh i would have worn
my homer in the bush's shirt but well
that's what that's i was just about to
start onto the chat and i was just about
to say something about like you and
tyrone
only two people who i know were in their
40s that's right man the only two people
you know in their 40s are me and tyrone
is my is my mic not
uh
what's going on john i know this is your
stream but there's no need to be a
selfish prick about it your mic is
higher than mine
i'm getting all kinds of comments in
there
john fix this this is your stream you're
supposed to make me shine too all right
companion according to the interface you
are now clipping so everybody let me
know if that sounds uh
deafening or or good enough
if your eardrums are bleeding
then we're on the right track
i love that spelling of koi yes
k-o-i-k-h-o-i
uh
i like how people go immediately to the
fish and not to uh
not to uh you know the the
state of being kind of um reserved and
alluring
john your your personality is so much
more reserved right now what is this
come on man it's your birthday stream
bring back that confident energy yes yes
yes
come on john bring back the energy that
makes it always uh uh uh my birthday
parties the stuff of legends
oh i'm overwhelmed by the love in here
right now ghost kids is happy oh my god
it's moving too fast now now i'm way too
loud
all right
all right i'm splitting the difference
and you got to raise yours up i'm
listening to us back right now in the
live stream okay
and now i'm raising mine
is that better
thank you for coming to my tech run
thank you for coming to my tech run
through this was always uh one of the
best parts of being in a play growing up
in
you know the 1970s was uh yeah you know
you have a play
you do a play and you have a tech run
through and then everyone's like hey
that went pretty well but you could fix
this that's what i want this to be today
um yeah definitely i'm 45 i'm definitely
not 31. brian sandler i love you too
angelica gullible is actually uh written
underneath your table so you should look
for that
um
in the grand mass
it's your birthday i can't do a good
jeff goldblum but i appreciate i would
love a a of a grand master uh
birthday wish
i love this you've started a whole
monster here because now everybody
thinks i'm actually 45. it's okay
john embrace your age there's no need to
be ashamed what's on greg's head it's a
fez because fezzes are cool it's it's
not embarrassing at all that you've your
best friend of all these years has been
19 years younger than you that's right
i like young people young minds keep me
young
and spry you know what i mean you see
the the thing with john is he doesn't
ever hold a birthday party for himself
he doesn't ever try to do anything he's
mr humble humble humble john is what we
call him around these parts of the woods
humble pie he's he gets all
self-conscious about it this is his
first birthday stream that he's ever
done too i know it's hard to fight that
level of attention upon yourself myself
anyway and now you know i already roast
john on the daily and now it's now it's
going to be double the roasting now i am
29 and 45. i occupy several ages at once
guys john um wally uh elder rissy in the
chat is saying why are you white why am
i white um i asked for it to be like
that when i when i was on deck uh up
above in christian heaven
uh baby jesus came to me and was like
hey you only get to choose once i know
there's a lot of cool options out there
that seem very interesting but what do
you think and i was like i just want to
be on top you know i want to have to try
minimally and be given everything so
that's why i'm white
so a couple people sent you some
birthday super chats buddy i know i am
literally trying to relocate them in the
chat because the super chat menu is not
working currently
uh and i saw one and i was like cool
okay aaron ryder while i have you on
screen i hope you all are doing well
happy birthday john thank you so much
aaron i appreciate you very so sweet of
you aaron wright i appreciate you dearly
uh thank you for coming to my birthday
ted talk i i swear i'm gonna i'm just
gonna click this one that's up here
because maybe it'll show up that way
thank you roboto studios roboto always
in the super chats with us thank you i
appreciate happy birthday says roboto
here i'm gonna
we're we're gonna go off-road here i'm
gonna attempt got this john all right
cool you can see that there are uh a few
people here you can see that the super
chat page isn't working that's what i
wanted
uh but i'm gonna pull this down here so
that you all can see that uh super chat
there oh look at that john you're so
you're so you want to make sure the
pizza is one of the john's best
qualities he always wants to make sure
others are shining around
i'm going to pull it back over here so i
can read it uh happy birthday wondering
if you'll get around to posting clone
wars episode reactions you seem to dig
the uh umbara clip you watched years ago
makes hating the jedi order
super easy barely an inconvenience
if it was uh a a marketable thing i
think that would be fun
it's not up to me but i would be happy
to do it marketable
of course it would be marketable oh okay
i'm trying to get john to watch clone
wars for about three years now i've been
inching my way through it as a a in in
the confusing you should watch it in
this order not the order in which it
aired order but uh which is not order
66.
so how far along are you in the clone
wars i couldn't tell you
i i know ahsoka and anakin and
you know
she's still an apprentice and and he's
still like oh you're you're annoying
ahsoka just chill out and stop being
like me
but better
john you just focus on talking to the
audience absolutely ooh sarah later hot
mom's podcast i want to i want to tune
in to you i wanna know what you're uh
all about that way
sarah williams and i'm sorry we'll try
and slow down but these things are high
octane we gotta keep it moving all right
it's all about the flow through this is
like a haunted maze the measure of
success is by how many people you can
crush through it in an hour so that's
what we're gonna do
today yes i am looking up at the camera
so i can definitely read these super
chats i am actually 25 logan i
appreciate you
i'm everything you know anything you
want to say is about me is true
i'm any age you want me to be
just uh you know do your best and uh try
to make it flattering and that's all i
ask you for i don't need any uh you know
any particular truth attached to me just
just the idea rorschach it's always
morbid time that's what i want for my
birthdays if anybody everybody could go
if they still have the morbius
re-release near you buy a ticket
even if you don't go to the movie just
buy a ticket um because i really hope
that morbius sweep continues i want more
bs2 i want more bs to be re-released a
third time if we can so please guys
that's all i want uh if you if you can't
leave a super chat or anything like that
if you can't comment at least go see
morbius and shout at the top of your
lungs when you get there that it's
morbid time
and you'll get a free gift this is super
impressive what you're doing john thank
you
thank you
you're really happy that you decided
this was this was a good idea
uh hey don't be so tense in the
shoulders buddy
it's so much easier when you have a
topic that's not yourself
i'm like i don't know what to do what
should i talk about me should i be like
oh what did i think of myself ask john
very personal questions yeah
super duper personal get as personal as
possible ask him about his traumatic
wounds i am a grandpa absolutely which
celebrity does john look like i got john
cusack a lot growing up i don't think uh
my current aesthetic looks very much
like him at all but uh but yes i used to
get john cusack a whole lot your your
dad posted photos of you in your younger
short hair
chubbier days
and uh i was like yeah that's when it
looked like john cusack yeah yeah that's
definitely my junk you can see it in my
cheeks and my nose you know do you kids
know john cusack
yeah i was gonna say do you kids know uh
the classic john cusack joints or do you
know the straight to dvd john cusack
joints do you know his um
it's funny bruce willis is like the
poster child for those except now it's
like a whole different issue when you
talk about that so now you can't use him
as a touchstone but it's the easiest
touchstone
look john i i could be able to help you
out here i could at least view the
probably the super chats here on camera
oh my god that would be amazing all
right john uh sky hornsby is saying to
you oh happy birthday john watching the
real rejects videos always is the
highlight of my day
also congratulations on sharing a
birthday with chris evans what chris
evans's birthday yeah man dang wait wait
wait is it a day or was it or was it
yesterday it doesn't matter anymore yeah
yeah
i i know it's cool because i share a
birthday in fact i'm gonna buy a cameo
from him now that it's not actually the
day cause you know it sucks to have to
work on your birthday like that but like
you know
one of my favorite bands has um
uh the same birthday one of the the lead
guy from one of my favorite bands is the
same birthday as me so uh that's cool
silver sun pickups his name is brian
o'bear
and uh he
has the same birthday as me
and uh i'm gonna get a cameo from him
but apparently chris evans does and
that's even better i don't think i could
afford a chris evans cameo
but uh yeah thank you jamie dove you are
a beautiful [ __ ] uh hey john you got a
super chat here from pandemic jones
pandemic we just shouted you out buddy
how are you thank you for for tuning in
oh okay he's got a speed round for you
oh goody all right you got to answer
this top of your head answer them no
questions no no no thinking all right
direct no thinking you better stop
thinking i'm thinking none
he says happy birthday john much love
speed run q a okay favorite hobby
favorite hobby guitar guilty pleasure
song
tick tock favorite movie
ed wood favorite actor actress
he almost said amber heard you guys
almost caught that i almost said amber
hurt and johnny
[Laughter]
uh oh golly favorite actor actress is
really really no thinking no thinking
god damn it maybe ethan all right ethan
hawk there we go and uh actress favorite
actress um
uh
so much for the no thinking
yeah i know
i'm just gonna say michelle yo for right
now because i i went to everything
everywhere again yesterday and i was
dazzled once again childhood celebrity
crush childhood celebrity crush uh does
misty from pokemon count yes it does
let's go there let's go john was
obsessed with misty from pokemon those
are the good old days man i had the
soundtrack and i would listen to misty's
song sometimes i'd be jealous of ash was
great all right we got fishman who sent
you a super chat five dollar super chat
look at these birthday presents thank
you so much happy birthday john i've
been listening to you guys for almost
two years now you guys are amazing keep
being awesome hey i'll try i'll try greg
greg contributes heavily to the to the
flow of awesomeness and i just try to
keep up with that so i'll do my best too
no guys john is not getting replaced the
team is expanding people in the chat
saying that
this is my send-off live stream and it
will be taken out back and executed
after this every time someone just comes
on the channel regularly like is john
getting replaced no
expanding the team i'm always getting
replaced all right um sally and coy are
replacing me can we put the regular chat
on screen andre black nerd will soon be
another uh replacement for me
if we miss a super chat please let me
know
um arkham x reaper okay hey john we've
got a question for you from arkham x
reaper i love it i want a question um 10
super chat for you buddy he says sup
guys got an off topic question but do
you think anthony starr could pull off
doctor doom in the mcu oh sure yeah yeah
i mean i feel like the problem with
anthony starr and all these conferences
he came up a lot in the comments for our
uh koi's and my wolverine is koi's video
koi's wolverine video that i was a prop
in and uh
my only problem with anthony stark oddly
enough i feel like uh i would see him as
doctor doom before i would see him as
like james howlett logan but i
feel like you think he could be you
think he could be a logan huh i can see
it it came up a lot in the comments and
i was kind of surprised because i
associate him with a more chris evans
type of build which is not what
wolverine is but uh at the same time i
could see him for sure as doctor doom
the only problem is i feel like
homelander has become so ubiquitous that
to do that would be distracting yeah it
would be like it would be like a weird
you're already watching him participate
in like a scathing deconstruction of
this so i feel like it would almost be
some kind of step backwards for him to
just then go do a regular super villain
you know but i would be i would be there
for it even still if they announced it
like he's such a terrific actor john
sarah campbell's asking is saying happy
birthday oh
sarah loving the new setup hope you both
have a great day we
are john slaved away putting this all
together while i just watched him this
yeah you weren't doing anything just
folded my arms and said my place you put
[ __ ] up now
get to work that's right
do you want to be paid
greetings to venezuela holy goodness
thank you for tuning in and somebody oh
damn i just lost it somebody said that
greg was a baby while i was taking bong
rips that's actually that's how we met
yeah he blew bong into
my baby hey baby
you're gonna love this
mix my come over here my formula milk
with
um here we go here oh hi roman hey raise
the world project now these are the
couple oh
on the social media it was a great video
you guys are so lovely
sabine it's being him right yeah and and
roger oh my god hot sabine uh to a long
happy and fun life john thank you much
love always sabine and roger thank you
love to you guys i'm gonna try not to
die extra hard now
for you guys yeah
definitely try to keep keep on
persisting for as long as possible uh
jevy reacts remember jeffy yeah what's
up evgeny uh jevy says happy birthday
john i'm still here guys love for malta
your videos make my day as always uh hey
dude go see jurassic world dominion
and let us know
let us know how they represented your
country
in the 20-minute sequence that they shot
there
oh we got omni media who just sent you a
20 super chat
says happy birthday man thank you
omnimedia everybody go subscribe to omni
media for my birthday go give him some
love michael b is is a legitimate human
being great reactor great commentator
and if you like this channel he's
another one of the people who eventually
be replacing me
[Laughter]
once he lives closer and
leaves indiana
that was funny john thanks good comedy
good comedy on your birthday today buddy
right in time to sign off
don't worry i got let's get the chat
back here we're trying to load this all
right
just hit that
yes all right yeah oh
hey it's working now hey i added a
little chat box oh it's working the chat
box to the thing so you can actually
kill the title overlay you can hit the
little eyeball oh cool yeah john's our
tech guy around here
um let's see here we're going from the
regular chat here mice
okay
oh wow okay we got from gallagher ghost
here oh i love galagos send you a ten
dollar super chat oh god
i shouldn't i'm only reading these to
help you out but
here why don't you read this one just so
we've got to read a few of them happy
birthday and cheers john i owe you a
drink the next time we see each other
mang oh dude let's drink let's drink
together wait a minute i know what i've
never seen john drunk ever really i
don't think i've ever seen you actually
drunk i think i've seen you like maybe
tipsy am i your profile pic or do we
just look similar
thank you though i really appreciate
that and i'm happy i'm and excited to
drink with you let's make that happen
let me know as soon as possible
john uh okay katie okay in the chat's
asking john have you ever oh wow oh
that's that's impressive uh john have
you ever killed an aunt with a
magnifying glass as a kid
no i was uh
i was more collecting like pill bugs and
things and poking holes in jar i was
more that kind of guy i was like let me
uh collect the ones that i think are
benevolent and hang out with them and
give them names i i didn't like to kill
stuff i still don't you wouldn't like i
don't like killing you wouldn't get like
a roly-poly poke it with a pencil watch
it slowly die the life slowly exude
out i mean now and then have a slight
grin just the left side of your cheek
slightest grin yeah yeah hmm that's mine
you weren't called into the principal's
eyes for having weird drawings about
your family home
no
we had two very covered in covered in
stabbed up rolly pollies is that it
covered in in decimated pill bugs that's
what i like i thought we had similar
childhoods we did we did but you know
when you have a 19 year old age
difference yeah yeah yeah yeah
i was i was i was cooking ants while you
were still in diapers kid it happens
john
uh jock jacques a talk five duck attack
five says happy 45th birthday john live
long and prosper thank you
thank you and thank you for perpetuating
this uh my 45 years of age hey man women
like older men hello to brazil i know
i'm starting to to prematurely get the
grays get the salt and pepper going
that's why he's holding on to his hair
that's right this
will preserve my use every keeps
commercial i'm just like not today
which uh hey go go if you need to go
sign up for keeps and use our affiliate
specter kid in the chat says i killed
the pigeon once but it was a mercy kill
because a cat had severed its wing it's
weird being in your position the things
i choose to read i know
i know right you catch straight things
and you're just like oh i feel like
giving that one a little a little boop
oh connie's saying or dear connie
[Music]
our beautiful connie singh um it says
here john best connie oh my god happy
birthday my favorite movie seat buddy
miss you guys miss seeing movies with
you i felt bad to i went and saw
everything everywhere again and i i
i feel like i should have invited you
i'm sorry
uh kieron's show on the chat says greg
is a psycho the stream isn't about me
i don't appreciate
people saying these things about greg on
my birthday all right this is basically
my son tim's asking if you watch chip
and dale yet i'll have you know that
like 200 000 people know that we watch
chip and dale already there's a reaction
on the channel i actually wasn't
watching it when we did that reaction i
was looking past the screens so really i
only heard the movie so i'm going to do
my own reaction some people wonder like
how do we get this production going so
high and john came up with this
brilliant idea of just taking the former
reactions and just putting different
footage in there and sometimes we just
lucked out that would be funny we just
[ __ ] out and we're like what are the
odds that we would say chip and dale in
this boy's reaction
[Laughter]
you know every now and again you'll
bring something some new layer out of a
thing that you didn't know was there
maybe the boys is a lot more whimsical
than we think it it's actually easier to
keep up with the chat on the phone
right called innovation john i know
next we'll get an ipad that just sits
here actually that'll be amazing i mean
we could easily get a refer but they
didn't release a new line so we could
probably get a a pretty cheap
refurbished one uh gallagher sent you a
five dollar super chat john oh gala
ghost thank you that is me and your
thumbnail pick i appreciate you the
beards just work for us haha that does
look like you is that you it looks like
me that's not you though it looks like
you from afar it looks like only with
the specs if only this uh monetization
tab worked so we can show it because
usually what we do on the streams is we
show like people's super chats and give
this special shout outs gravity falls
going up tomorrow we had to do a a big
move so we were a little bit behind but
gravity falls go up tomorrow oh
did we get new zealand stump uh by going
off road no no go read a joke stump
happy birthday john all the best from
new zealand i would i would love to
visit new zealand someday i feel like
you know the the wildlife that you guys
have
is a little daunting because it said
that everything out in the outback wants
to kill you
uh you know
which uh i understand you know australia
and new zealand not the same but
probably some similar uh wildlife but i
would definitely i i have some friends
from out there and i would love to visit
someday
so thank you for helping uh
make my 55th birthday
dude field uh uh exotic yes alexander
mcmillian uh saying a five dollar super
chat saying happy birthday john got a
specific question for you okay what was
your favorite type of food as a child
and is it the same today
as a child as a child
it was a child my favorite food as a
child
that's an excellent question i
had a weird taste i mean
if i'm thinking of things that are that
are like quite specific i mean like
as a young child i was probably just
like give me buttered toast and fruit
punch but uh there was a restaurant we
would go to when i was uh young
in ojai california called avanti it's a
uh
italian restaurant it was very lovely
and they had um i i feel like i would
often get like i liked fettuccine a lot
but they had this really really great
angel hair pasta that i would get there
so uh that was that was among my
favorite foods growing up or my mom's
meatloaf that was that was the thing i
loved growing up while we're on this
question why don't you tell me you would
get from jack in the box when you were
like second grade
i didn't start going to jack-in-the-box
until i was older
uh but when i did go to jack-in-the-box
ultimate cheeseburger spicy chicken
sandwich and uh
some configuration of
fries some of that buttermilk it's crazy
to me that your parents would get you
all that knowing like how much more
health conscious they are now oh yeah
it's weird like that we were like kids
and you just get these like
fat ass burgers yeah
it's weird it's uh the philosophy
the eating philosophy at home was such
that it was like most of the time we're
stalking like non-fat low-fat stuff so
like most everything on hand at home is
like
really health-conscious or at least more
like
fat and calorie conscious
and then when we would go out for yeah
if it was like burger day then it's like
yeah have fun yeah
uh but yeah yeah yeah that's delicious
um vol vojtek raja sent a a super
sticker oh that says hype with a hippo
hippo thank you for 80 bucks oh my god
thank you thank you avoid check wow i
appreciate that very kind z-a-r where
are you in the world
uh greg let john slap you for his
birthday
god give me a little give me a little
smack
[ __ ] see you guys heard it you guys
heard how am i supposed to get hard if
you're
fast enough
this is the
it's i'm telling you rejects after dark
i want it that was going on
let's do it
let's do it yeah
you know it'll be like old times it'll
be like being back at uh you know one of
those old goth clubs we used to go to oh
azanti sent you a twenty dollar super
chat shop yes thank you i refuse to
believe john is 45. it sounds like a
great joke
happy birthday j.h
john tell him it's the truth it's the
truth i am uh i'm 55.
okay
there's no right to over there's no need
to oversell i'm 44
all right eight years old you're you're
45 years old it's okay there's nothing
to be embarrassed about no you don't
need to round down all right you don't
need to round down i'm just i'm
approaching my 60s have you got your
prostate exam yet i have a colonoscopy
once we sign off of here oh good thank
god that's always a great birthday
present to give yourself yes
do you have the doctor slap you
yes i do i i have them slap my bum and
my face uh while the camera goes in just
so that i'm just completely distracted
the entire time you know it's kind of
crazy to me that this whole chat most of
it is about john being 45 and i thought
all of you guys knew that by now that's
right man no they needed you to clarify
that for them who would have thought a
thumbnail would be so revealing i know
the truth is out there scully the truth
you know what i've never seen any of the
x-files wow i've never seen any x-files
i was looking online the other day i was
like would these make good reactions
what about the movie uh nope i've seen
the movie i want to believe or whatever
it's called yeah yeah
the theme song by imagine dragons dennis
ellis
dennis ellison you have five dollar
super chat saying happy b day john thank
you so much oh oh there's a great
question for you john i love questions
uh what series or movie announced that
isn't out yet are you most looking
forward to and why
um
announce that isn't out yet
um
golly
um
is a series it has to be series no no
movie or series it isn't out yet what
series or movie
i'm most anticipating right now no yeah
uh nope for sure nope nope is the the
next one in fact i was having that
dilemma the other day i was like
should i go see this in the theaters or
should i wait until it comes out on vod
so we can react [ __ ] that we're watching
in the theaters okay yeah i was gonna
say like that's a movie that like i want
to see in the theater let's face it we
get more views if we you know did a
reaction here but
but everywhere watching that in the
theater every once in a while the love
of cinema prevails yeah yeah once in a
while the need to make everything about
hey ren ryan the chat is saying gotta
say john the jesus locks are looking
healthy today thank you i i you know
what uh you on on my day off yesterday i
washed my hair and i combed it too uh
michael mac is giving some
recommendations for clone wars for you
with a five dollar super chat saying
there's an essential episode playlist
for clone wars on disney plus also left
you guys a stream labs donation a
message much love from scotland thank
you much much love to scotland
we've been watching peter capaldi
uh on doctor who on patreon so uh that's
uh that's quite super exciting
okay hey i found i i caught up to the
super chats in the menu here
so at least
we can get comprehensive a little bit no
way josh yes sorry no way i can put
these on screen i've kind of been
enjoying doing it this way but sure why
not i mean sure sure i just want to make
sure that we're just keep missing
anybody yeah i'll keep screenshotting
them miguel leger dave we got a big one
coming up oh you got a big ass one
coming off john
oh hype for the future super chats
so excited happy birthday miguel legere
lejay happy burnt day john they got to
replace amber heard with a seahorse in
aquaman
hey seahorses hey let's wait for her
variety interview
so everyone will change their minds
all right oh the amber heard johnny depp
trial is is just absolutely my favorite
thing i'm sure my brother's gonna be
doing some great reactions to that
variety interview for you guys i love
that opinion where people are like i
hope it never ends
you guys no no no you want it i hope it
ends for everyone uh thank you so much i
hope one day a bunch of people rally
behind a woman fighting for the same
cause is what i hoped for
you know
don't get greedy yeah don't get greedy
with the whole right a famous woman a
famous woman yeah you know if meryl
streep can do yeah yeah yeah maybe like
a super famous one maybe that you know
celebrity that i have a preconditioned
love for prior to knowing anything about
who they really are yeah yeah tote bags
no that's that's the way to do it that's
the way greg is the porn butt
yes
of course we need one every live stream
that's our administrator is whoever's
spamming porn this is always our
administrator did you pull up the chats
i did all right let's do it i'll make
sure we're on track all right this guy
is older than my uncle
you're older than this guy's uncle i
know cause i'm 45 years old it is very
possible to betting on the age to be
older
cryomaniac 2099 says happy birthday john
and congrats on the marvel follow greg
it is not because i can't read it over
there
oh dude i got you covered there you go
and whenever i switch windows it it
screws it up
because youtube is the best actually i
think marvel accidentally followed me
i'll take it you know because they
unfollowed me
right after no
why dude i don't know i checked that i'm
like i don't think they're actually
following me who do they think you were
i don't know
that's messed up maybe someone on marvel
was like don't follow that guy he's a
hack yeah we've he's a chill for us it's
a show for us we don't want to follow
the shields
[Laughter]
happy b day john where the punch got
where the cake punch guys is that the
latest one i don't think it's literally
jamal it's snow it's like one of the
earliest ones yeah yeah keep going down
yeah
these are may 29th now yeah let's go
back to a preview let's go back to the
one million subs live stream let's do it
all right thank you jamal simmons i
think i think that's your name akkason
or tyrone john go ah
caron
we got roberto studios yes aaron ryder
hope you all are doing well happy
birthday to john i think we got you but
thank you again even if we didn't alto
voltage
happy birthday john here's a little
something for the single moms
countdown is that countdown convention
yes the single moms convention is where
i will be
as a 40 something year old man in the
right age range
yeah
a lot of women your age looking to
settle down who haven't found true love
yet
can you call them cougars if you're in
the same age bracket comment below well
you don't look 45 so
technically you can i know it's
surprising how not 45 i'm glad to look
they meant to follow blind wave chill
levels oh of course they did they need
to check up on their investments that's
a funny comment yeah
i really appreciate that one roger
krishnan thank you so much buddy happy
birthday john i appreciate you
it's been too long i feel like one day
you know we've met a few patrons we need
to meet
we need to meet
that's it that's all i have to say putty
we got to fly out to meet eric horstman
one day i know we got to do a national
tour of different cities meeting
different patrons and friends yeah you'd
think it would be like oh my god big
events every time but it's like nope two
people showed up that's what it's going
to be like yes hey
it wasn't empty
give it that
putty
man what is your favorite reaction you
have done oh
come on john name it tuffy
favorite react i mean we talked about
this in the in the million subs the
upgrade trailer is always a highlight
that was such a cool wonderful uh moment
there
trying to think what was the best like
movie reaction i really enjoyed uh doing
willy's wonderland and bill and ted
because those were such
uh especially bill and ted was like such
a ah like you know we're here and we're
sharing it and you helped introduce me
to bill and ted and so like you know
that was like a really fun special one i
did yeah i mean you guys you and and
some other folks were talking about it
at school and you would do the excellent
and then uh i i took that home and then
my mom was like oh yeah the love of
excellent adventure you know here have a
double cheeseburger
let's order let's order a pizza and get
a copy of bogus journey glued to the box
because that was a promo that was
happening oh no i have a pizza hut
so that's why that's how i got my first
copy of bogus journey red skies s
j
i g j d yeah
birthday big sexy ooh
a big sexy that's right that's what they
call me i'm gonna change my name tag now
from now on no more jay bird it's just
big sexy we got sky hornsby
yeah all right and i'm glad to highlight
your day paco
san miguel is what i'm seeing thank you
for the cake
it looks like a delicious cake too this
looks like whenever cartoon cakes are
like these shades of pink i'm always
like i want to lick it
and chew it and swallow it and digest it
ganny gameplay
i gameplay emojis and i feel like in
certain situations that are not
appropriate however i feel like since
there's an emoji for every occasion they
should be more appropriate because they
help clarify what you're actually trying
to
uh tonally say as well as verbally say
ooh mang i think
john age is like tom cruise many happy
returns thank you that's my that's i
hang that picture up on my wall and
every day i just touch his nose
and i'm like for you tom
and i run down the street to greg's new
place
have you seen any
what's your favorite time
what's the tom cruise movie name one
um a few good men that's definitely my
favorite
raid man that's also my favorite the the
firm
definitely my favorite goodwill hunting
he's in that
reindeer games also in that
uh my favorite tom cruise movie
oh the mummy no
mine's collateral i think collateral is
probably the yeah in fact it's it's
olivia's too yeah we were talking about
that in line at top gun maverick pepper
tom yeah that's a great yeah i think
that one because it's like yeah watching
him actually full-on play that character
uh i'll never forget seeing that movie
in the theaters so yeah collateral and
then uh
god maverick is just such a cool movie
so that is great if you want see that's
the thing is i guess for like
quintessential like big smile tom cruise
i'll go maverick but for like putting on
some range absolutely collateral
pandemic jones we got you i appreciate
your speed round love you hell reaper
john talking about jesus as if he's not
actually jesus you're fooling nobody my
lord
i appreciate that was a test of faith
and you passed the test well unlike the
the rock and roll crowd the jesus look
is common it is so we go to bar sinister
i see a gazillion people who look like
you yeah there's not a lot of people
that look like you there's a line for
people who look like me at first this is
people who do like movie talk [ __ ]
online don't a lot don't look like you
yeah except for that one guy from blind
with yes who i'm often confused for eric
eric harris
fellow quirky merc eric whiteley but
thank you
many blessings upon you and hey keep
being good because uh dad is is pleased
uh
michael mack
disney plus has an ass oh thank you yes
thank you for that clarification i i'm
glad that they on their official
platform laid out which episodes don't
matter and which work was thrown down a
time hole by those animators because i
don't want to engage with those episodes
fishman
happy birthday john
been listening to you guys for almost
two years now you guys are amazing keep
being awesome well thank you i
appreciate you you've got a cool name i
like it alexander mcmillian someone in
the chat says heady bud says floppy
nipples floppy nipples that's the
opposite of nipple chills yeah just like
exuded nipples
which
maybe maybe you should uh take a test if
that's the case our brand manager is
messaging us in the whatsapp should we
uh respond right now is it tom
yes
um yeah
so uh yeah he's asking us about this
thing
i'm just gonna give our brand manager a
bunch of crap for not wishing you a
happy birthday he wished me one
seventeen minutes ago
right it's right here on my curtain way
to go it's um thank you tom tom digital
appreciate you very much um but yes
apparently tom has been invited to thor
with us so
well i'm not going to say hi no never
alexander mcmillian you'll be like
unless you got a brand deal for me we're
not talking happy b day john what's your
favorite flavor of ice cream nice
i mean the classic fave was always
cookies and cream because sometimes you
get like a big
full on like chunky monkey ass cookie
and that's like the mo that's like
finding treasure as a kid so
cookies and cream absolutely or you know
as an adult if you can find like a
gelato that has an interesting flavor
give me like a tiramisu gelato i'm all
over that
i thought you'd be crazier john's like
mr flavor guy well if you take me to a
yogurt store
i'm going to
to make an abomination it's like i'm
going to put every flavor of yogurt that
appeals to me in that cup
attempted to be sectioned apart from
each other
and then i'm just going to start dumping
every kind of topping i want and then
that becomes just like like when buddy
of the elf makes the the chocolaty candy
spaghetti and elf basically you still
put it together like someone's ordering
this and you're delivering it to them
you know i'm just like it's gonna get
messed up in one second you're like let
me make sure this is a nice presentation
yeah
cause fave food's a ritual food is art
yeah there's art and science colliding
in a beautiful uh functional package
more like i mean he doesn't drive home
let's go
you know
my face kind of goes to each their own
it's total [ __ ] the way stores throw
out food that just is not
aesthetically pleasing when it's just as
good to eat so hey to each their own i
know a lot of restaurants waste a lot of
food there's a lot of food waste in this
world
it's
it's sad and it points out the weird
aspects of our league legal process
because partly it's like a legal
liability uh but anyway lily i cannot
believe you're that old whoa
john sold i know i thought you were
younger love the channel no regrets love
the patreon content so much love the
channel no real rights i do not regret
this free subscription much as many as
people try to tell me to not subscribe
to these guys you're gonna be sorry i
don't have any regrets about it man
sorry they're all writing my book and i
stand by it just for the real reason you
can never unconvince me of this
arkham reaper sup guys got an off topic
question but we got it we got that one
got it anthony got started we're not
playing favorites here john
stump we got him you got it yeah this is
when i figured out
we got our good raise the world got it
definitely did jevy got him definitely
trina stanford happy birdie john
thank you i appreciate i love birds we
used to have birds when i was a kid
michael you
thank you for the moment of silence we
got omni we got michael you again
uh hey
mine is tomorrow be safe well hey happy
45th birthday to you 45th birthday you
old son of a gun yeah you old
rifle you
gala ghost
john is most cr moist critical's
long-lost brother oh oh me and moist
critical he's also 45 today yes
all the best from new zealand again
thank you jack attack i'll have you know
david ganny got me this hat and if you
guys watch gravity falls you exactly
know where this hat comes from yeah it's
from the mystery it's in style guys yeah
it's relevant still
jack attack happy 45th birthday john
live long and prosper greg is reading
this you too
is that what the comments is
connie love you gala ghost love you as
well
uh the beards just work for us they do
alexander what alexander
favorite type of food we got that we got
the hype all right we're catching up
uh uh yes okay it's sante we got that we
got you so keep on disbelieving
dennis ellis
yes we got that
all right
michael mack we got yep all right
ronaldo torres torres we're caught up
now let's go the man who warms our
hearts to the man who warms our hearts
we wish you the best of birthdays though
you don't know each of us i know we'll
be lucky to call you a friend oh thank
you is that really nice no one ever says
it about me they said about you for a
reason
john is one of the most compassionate
caring individuals you will ever meet oh
i mean that sincerely had a whole spiel
with him about it the other day thanks
yeah
more caring than everyone else i've ever
known i mean that's sincerely
very kind don't get all self-conscious
on me now you [ __ ] i don't care about
anything
over here stylist [ __ ] for the salmon
dean
we are
very much sam very much the same i'm
very much the dean
but neither one of us are anywhere near
as cool as those two yes we'll get there
someday
in season 15 of the real rejects we'll
be grizzled
but hey we just started season 10 so
come on over to patreon uh but yeah that
was very sweet thank you for writing
that like you would a birthday card i
appreciate that
whale a density
happy day of birth john thank you hey
john
um
who's your favorite sith and favorite
jedi my favorite sith and my favorite
jedi
you know darth vader know we won you
know
the only two choices
um i mean when i was a kid i thought
darth maul was the [ __ ] i thought i had
action figures of darth maul i had that
thing
uh they have uh that star wars toy where
the action figures would come with the
little um like chip that you then had to
buy an extra communicator device and
then you would scan the chip and then it
would like repeat dialogue from the
characters nice so i had one for darth
maul uh favorite jedi is dash rendar a
jedi
if dash rendar is a jedi i choose dash
rendar
but if not
then i'm going with new fan favorite
that everyone had heard of not just the
clone wars fans before obi-wan shouted
him out quinlan voss who i know tons
about as a character really he's
watching t-shirts about quinlan foster
you know he's got that cool hairdo um
he looks kind of like a native american
guy which is nice for diversity in star
wars yeah which is something that
everyone on the internet is on board for
uh-huh yeah i mean people love diversity
especially in the star wars universe
there's so many different aliens
including one native american looking
guy
uh but mace windu as a kid always uh i
don't know there's something about sam
jackson that purple lightsaber that
always got me so
mason frost i think or is it mazel
uh happy birthday you sexy mmf doom
to keep it fun six month [ __ ] shaking
that is sorry it took me back to a dave
matthews show i went to once we heard
about this ezra miller crap
uh about this kid this like native
american kid he groomed who's like
living with him now and his parents want
him to come home and now they're trying
to find him and the authorities can't
find him or
is like
yeah the parents were like our our kid
is is
is gay and something something else but
now ezra miller has them convinced
they're trans and i was like whoa this
is such a weird rabbit hole of
specificities i mean the shocking part
to me is they just can't [ __ ] find
desert miller
i know they owe that thing too yeah it's
like they're trying to serve in papers
or serve them papers and now they're
just nowhere to be found that's [ __ ]
wild man
anyway i don't i i am so fascinated to
know what's how this is all going to
make for a weird flash trailer reaction
to that much
i'm excited but reminded of the real
world my question now becomes
this desk is great my question now
becomes what
what is the breaking point like how far
can we go with this before they're like
we can't release this movie
because they're like they have like in
releasing it i think warner brothers is
hiding i don't feel like they're pro
they're probably like we can't let him
be found for the next year and half
maybe yeah
lester miller is in the wb vault yeah
right now yeah just like chilling out in
the server version yeah yeah oh hey
that's smart but like if this doesn't
get better when are they going to like
at what point do they finally come out
and say listen guys we have this movie
y'all have seen the news we will not
release this now no they're not going to
do that like they i feel like they can't
but also i'm like what's the line i just
want to know what they can't no there's
no way there's too much there's too much
in that movie i know and that's and you
can't [ __ ] kevin spacey that [ __ ]
like you gotta no and that's the thing
is is we're finally reaching a point
where it can't be fixed where like you
either release the movie or you choke
millions and millions and millions of
dollars
and uh i'm fascinated anyway
uh should do a video on it the day the
flash next flash trailer comes up yes
one back to back yeah one thumbnail of
us looking excited
looking like pretty disappointed
yeah
grouchy faces where do you guys
but maize and frost wants to know uh to
keep it fun what superhero names would
you give each other
oh frostbite
oh that's a cool name yeah frostbite
damn
yeah dang dude yeah
it kind of just came to me i don't
really have a power mind maybe something
do this
i just like the name frostbite that's
yours i give you frostbite cool i'll
take it whitey i could see you having
like ice powers just you getting like
[ __ ] the blue eyes and
the crystal hair
yeah yeah my hair turns white and blue
it should be like frost
the actual
killer frost sure yeah sure yeah i'll be
that i'll just be frost frostbite your
your superhero name for me is uh
secondhand
ouch
no no like a second hand because you're
so precise with time secondhand you
could probably control time sounds like
you're calling me sidekick
or like a used that would be equals here
yeah yeah yeah i'll call you like stop
watch your name
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'd be a cool for like a speedster
person yeah yeah yeah
speedster but with a little more control
over time and space yeah stopwatch
that's a cool name
[ __ ] we were onto something here we're
doing it
frustrating
frostbite and stopwatch dude we freeze
in totally different ways
yeah
i freeze time literally you freeze it
figuratively adam from fan pops happy
birthday john much love from denise and
i we loved meeting you and coy at the
multiverse of madness how much this
person is how much adam contributed i
know holy crap i actually it's so far
away
thank you that's a lot thank you so much
that's very generous of you i very much
very very much appreciate it we can send
you john's bank information if you just
want to wire things throughout the day
to him directly that's right there will
be links down below to my amazon
wishlist my paypal my cash app my only
fans uh my uh
you know my house address will be there
uh
you know the floor plan to your home
the blueprints
the pink slip to my car title to the
house the title of the house yeah yeah
yeah all my various credentials it's all
there it's all there count it it's all
there uh you guys journey on youtube is
what keeps us going to grow our own
channel also we love john's christopher
what i'm going to read this again
much love
from denise
and i
we loved meeting you and koi at the
multiverse of madness premiere
hoping to meet you again with greg
next time
no no
never
no separately only no i i would love for
all of us to meet and thank you for
chiming back in again because you you
came to the million subs live stream too
so i feel like yeah that's
ah so thank you very much
look how much he remembers that's really
good that's really really karen and
seriously like this and i'm like who the
[ __ ] is this guy well no you're like oh
i don't remember yeah that's so sweet
one two on the red car and on the red
carpet obviously i don't know coy
less so than me but like you know like
me walking around the red carpet like
i'm the least of anyone's focus so like
you know with someone's like oh i'm
excited about you and not just about
you know benedict cumberbatch is over
there uh you know that makes your day
extra so you know when you're when
you're someplace glitzy and someone's
like but you you're like oh but they
probably don't have access to men in a
cumberbatch
oh they could get it yeah they have
tried hard enough yeah it's true yeah
they're they they settled
okay what do we get access to i guess
we'll talk to you then
john and supes
let's go let's go jonathan supes baby
frank and frank and cow cow
whoa happy day around the sun john
you were the guy that collected you were
the guy that collected spores and fungus
that's right he could have been yes i am
spangler i mean gone
is that who i would be as a ghostbuster
out of the three of us would i be a
spangler
you're you're easily uh
you're vegan
does that make coy dan aykroyd
i think koi would definitely
yeah
and then sally is winston
uh yeah spores and fungus boy shield
vids
nah
happy birthday john
how john
happy birthday john love your agents of
shield reactions uh would either of you
react to the time traveler's wife hbo
series only six episodes
uh not the rachel mcadams movie dude
it's only six episodes this one's like
30 hours of work at all yeah it's only
30 hours uh get on it john i mean
there's make it happen man is this chris
simeon as shield viz somebody commented
this and i need to get back to you on
actual patreon i mean i'm always
interested in this stuff i it would it
would need to undergo the same process
it would need to be gauged for both
patreon and outside interest uh there is
demon slayer at the very least that i
need to hop back on once
shield will be done first so once
shield's done i need to hop back on that
uh i got a request for atlanta although
i don't think that will pan are you
gonna cover everything everywhere all at
once
i i would be absolutely a billion
percent thrilled to cover that in any
way i can but i i've seen it in theaters
i will not be able to
do a first-time reaction for you have
you guys seen everything everywhere all
at once
i it is incredible
did you did you do your video four times
i've seen it oh good
yeah good i reacted to four times
because i thought the first reaction
wasn't good enough good and i was like
all right i can do this i can [ __ ]
but dude the problem is this would make
a great video because then you could do
four reactions all in four different
outfits four different versions of you
inter-splice them throughout have it be
as though you're oscillating through the
multiverse while watching the movie i
have never seen a trailer for this movie
and good i didn't either i haven't seen
any of it good
all i know is that i saw like five
seconds of a clip from the marshall club
brothers on their social media fighting
with michelle yo that that's all i saw
was like five seconds of that because
they were posting it all the time it's
cool that you know that they're that
they're involved i i i wish that it was
a surprise yeah well [ __ ] them then yeah
freaking i didn't realize i didn't
realize until i saw it and then brian
showed up on screen and i was like what
is happening
yeah yeah yeah i mean i'm gonna do a
reaction i already bought it it's just
about making some time for it i'm so
excited i was gonna do it today but
someone had a stupid birthday [ __ ] that
guy
okay kai says shut the [ __ ] up 45
looking good happy birthday john thank
you i'm definitely truthfully 45 years
old
ricky robot says
happy birthday john that's you oh good
my parents almost named me john good
that was your name hey but my aunt beat
my parents to it so now i'm ricky
your aunt just burst into the delivery
it's a ricky he's all right
named john
that was all right yes that was a
fascinating story
i'm glad that thank you for the super
thank you rick ricolus ricky oh my god
there's an open knife down here oh it
did
just like the pillow i was like that's
not right
uh yes but thank you ricky i appreciate
that uh hey we're gonna do the live
stream and i was like we need to get a
table because the this table is awesome
we have we have a tv now to react off of
things for because we're like might as
well make life more enjoyable when we're
doing the stuff
and um
but because this is tv we got to be way
further away from like the keyboards and
all that so we bought like a wireless
keyboard a wireless mouse and then i
rushed to target and the first table
that looked like this might do the trick
i just grabbed it and shed it out of
there
yeah this is great
yeah like yeah especially i mean you
know
a three-person live stream we might need
to get a little creative but this is
good this is great i mean no this gives
you enough space to kind of as long as
yeah as long as you can have a control
station somewhere that's not your knees
yeah yeah yeah yeah well gay uh you're a
john in my heart ricky uh cool
sangria coco sangria coco sangria happy
boring day john and greg is that
different reading from here
come
look from my mind
look for my vantage yeah yeah it does
look different you're right yeah you're
right
yeah you know spatial spatial things
happy b day happy boring day john i like
that phrase born day and greg is right
jason bourne
it's born debbie born day born i want to
find out who's gonna tell me where he
lives tell me where he eats i don't know
where he sleeps eats shits and what his
birthday is boring day i don't know what
his bro i want to know he wants i want
to know what he wishes when he blows out
the candles i want to know what kind of
cake it is
that should be the next born film yeah
he's just trying to remember dave he's
trying to remember if it's actually his
birthday or not he's at a birthday party
he's like wait a minute this isn't right
this isn't my real birthday or is it
treadstone ah
greg is right you're one sexy old man oh
thanks uh love you guys have fun tonight
45 man i like being that's already right
it's a good age it's my age it's the age
that i am for real truthfully dude
tyrone says um
he says i knew i'd like john
for more than just him being a cool guy
we're both gemini's he was born a day
before me we're both about to be 45 this
year dude tyrone and we're both friends
with the mighty greg albert we are both
friends of the mighty greg oh my god
that is what the text says
first i was like is that a real text are
you are you true uh yeah dude me and
tyrone 45 club i didn't realize you were
a gemini you do realize from here on out
you got to go by
45 now i am or else you've created a
month how can people ever trust our word
now if they think if they if they're
like
wait you're not 45 they're never gonna
trust us now this is one lie oh my god
our our integrity is questioned in all
corners of life no this is good i'm
happy to be the first person in history
to lie about their age and make it much
older and be like no one's going to
guess
partly because it's it's just so far up
there
so i i it's weird it creates this this
great sort of
interesting compliment where people are
like no way you look amazing yeah man
so i probably look better than i do for
what my uh age is which is 45. some
people are saying i honestly thought
john was uh 35 mr axel in the chat says
thank you
he could be thank you see that's the
thing though is then people guess higher
and you're like oh damn
uh but thank you damn dally even though
35 is lower than 45 which i am there's
some beautiful people here wishing you a
happy birthday john oh i wish i could
read them all
when you leave i'm just going to sit
here and read the chat chat john will
reply to every one of your live stream
comments oh jeffy reacts still living
with dinosaurs here in malta i hope
you're safe
from uh
the critics carter lovejoy happy
birthday john hope it's a great one i
hope you're having a great day carter
lovejoy have you guys played the new
video game yet called the quarry from
the developers of until dawn i've heard
john have you i haven't but i've heard
of it why haven't you john because i
don't i got time for video games
i i bought a switch a while ago
and i i took it out of the packaging and
that's how far we are
i have luigi's mansion three friday the
13th doom and something else uh sonic i
i got it to play sonic games to catch up
for the sonic movie which i did uh but
since then i have not played a video
game i would love to play the quarry
though i was going to start a video game
the other day but i figured i should
finish up the show love is blind first
oh how did it go and then i started
barry
and oh baby i gotta catch up with barry
now he's way behind on
i gotta catch up with the rest of barry
i've only seen season one oh dude
barry's great uh
yeah i forgot how short that show is
it's only 30 minutes yeah i always
thought like it's like a full 30 minutes
right not like 22 30. but that's why i
like delayed so much on watching it
because i i thought like i got like
another hour show yeah yeah and then i
looked at him like oh damn i can knock
out like four of these in two hours
that's right because that's how math
works yeah
yeah buddy
if i don't take any breaks if i just go
straight through them i skip all the
interstitial graphics maybe if i skip
some credits i could save a few minutes
never lose your nerd how some people
think you look 25 some people are saying
you look 35 john
i'll take it all are we going to the
world premiere of thor love and thunder
apparently i think so
apparently unless we get kicked out i
hope it's good otherwise i gotta crap on
that movie outside of the theater i know
it's always a good feeling to do when
you're at a premiere yeah i know
screening especially when they got you
know the mouse is listening to you yeah
and they got bugs there's a publicist
left yet oh thank god
this was not my fault this
i hope it's good i want it to be great
i don't know it's probably going to be
amazing i haven't heard anything about
it it's the first tyco sequel it's the
first taika sequel yeah that's true also
shouts out to wellington paranormal last
stream somebody asked what's a whole
universe you would watch and i said uh
you know movies shows included yeah i
said what we do in the shadows but i
failed to mention that not only is there
a movie in a show but there's also
wellington paranormal which is very uh
charming and fun there have been so many
nice comments in the chat about real
rejects but specifically you john no
guys people love you i love you guys
people think you're younger than me
really
that good old white blood that's right
white don't
frighten people with age marks you guys
want to know a funny story really quick
i want to keep this all about john
but recently
there was i got offered to they're
they're recording me to help to co-host
some some event right um
host was a white guy oh no this uh
host was a white guy boy
yeah i didn't want to reveal revealing
about it jesus wait
and you're revealing koi is it tyrone
your white friend tyler no no not cory's
going to be mad at me [ __ ] it let me
i'll apologize later ace cabrera coy
doesn't watch any of these videos unless
he's in the video so that's fine so make
sure to timestamp this moment and send
it to koi so i can talk with them about
it at 6pm specifically today
specifically i'm not trying to be
secretive about it you're like koi
you're talking about right i you know i
didn't know so i was guessing
you didn't have to confirm that
you didn't have to confirm the guess
that's true i didn't but um apparently
i'm too white looking to be to have two
that i have to have two they wanted
people of like a more of a diversity and
so they're like wow too white
and me
do i no no no one has ever guessed me to
be a white guy before
you're caucasian aren't you yeah like
really this is the first to be told this
before i am surprised to hear that that
that is surprising to me because yeah i
feel like
oh that's so weird this is not weird
yeah
that was the event that i was
being told like oh i was like sure i'll
do it fine um but um
yeah is that what happened yeah i had no
idea too white it's the circumstance wow
that's a real thing that happens in this
business guys people there they go by
they do well they will go by ethnicity
and this is stuff that apparently you
shouldn't be revealing to people but
[ __ ] it uh yeah they go by ethnicity and
color and be like all right if we got a
white person we got to make sure the
other person's like really black or
something
the blackest person
we gotta go like we gotta show we are
embracing diversity at all costs or
something
and we're like
greg albert too white
okay sure no
i'll go to any person on the street i'll
ask them if i'm too white i wasn't even
offended i was more like that's funny
me
what an interesting opinion fascinating
i never would have thought
do you have any kids john all of them i
have all the kids
random questions from borrow kids
uh here we go borrow kids you know what
the [ __ ] that's such a creepy guy
you know if i need me
to go and creepy people expect that kind
of humor you know if i'm going to a
chuck e cheese i'm like hey kid let me
let me borrow you for a minute then we
get inside the door i'm like all right
go do your thing just just meet me back
here for when we leave so it doesn't
look like i'm i'm you know here alone
you know discord thinks john is way
better than greg
racist this is the inevitable comment
that was bound to come in when you do a
john celebration stream because of my
whitening someone's going to come in and
be immediately compare us good and let
them think that
john bode's better for me believe it or
not
may the lord jesus bless you for all
your sins john
affiliate spirit to something man
uh let's go into it oh we got some soup
we got some stream labs for you we got
some laboratories damn well i'm gonna
keep going in here for you then while
you're loading that
all righty
can't read this from there dude greg you
look like me someone says
oh you look like somebody will you watch
the psych movies john
absolutely 100 percent i will
and i'm so thrilled so very thrilled
that they continue to make them
even though the show has concluded
because it seems
sorry it seems as though that show is
certainly a family and it seems like
they will keep making the movies for as
long as they can so i am totally
thrilled especially as
as much as that show
demonstrates
film and film love and literacy
i'm very excited to see them turn into
movies shane rose in the chat says you
guys are my second favorite reaction
channel after the cyber nerds from the
uk oh thank you thank you i've always
wanted to come second place to cyber
nerds hey man it's a respectable place i
definitely watched their channel you
know the cyber girls don't you john
yeah yeah yeah they're best friends of
ours we're number two we're number two
to them that's what we tell them
michael mack tested positive for covid
this morning and feel holy balls feel
like poo
but your new brooklyn video made me
laugh just want to show that i do but i
i absolutely can't read it if i do that
you could try i could read them from
here
yeah
you read it good job sean you ready you
read it perfectly
brooklyn video made me laugh which i
needed i'm glad to hear that happy
birthday john congrats on the news set
up much love from scotland
greg i'll give you one more chance to do
a good accent we are from scotland
youtube thumbnails logo maker flippin
i'm geror butler's american accent
your best scottish is is gerard butler's
best american
[Music]
flev doran happy happy b day birthday to
you john you look very good for 45. i'm
pretty sure gerard butler does say the
title of his own movies in every one of
his movies i am a gamer
i
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
this is my british accent
that says the ugly
thing
what are some more
gotta get like liam neeson and pierce
brosnan and
gerard butler all they do all the people
who can't do other accents
i have a very particular set of skills
i am terminator i am tomb raider 2
cradle of life
uh hey thank you flev cheers to another
45 it'll be my 45th birthday for the
next like 14 years
uh chill level television
felice
campoliano's birthday john damn
i can't believe you're already 69 hella
old [ __ ] old man nothing but
the best wishes for you lovely gent also
i highly recommend checking out
sugarpine's
sugarpine 7's alternative lifestyle
series on youtube it's a great treat to
watching your birthday well thank you i
appreciate the recommendation john get
on it i like alternative things john get
on it i like an alternative you have all
the time in the world my friends have so
much time and i never lament otherwise
i i'm just always like god i have too
much time another break my i couldn't
keep god i'm so
bored like
the older i've gotten the more i've
realized that boredom is the ultimate
luxury like boredom
i anticipate i look forward to being
bored now because if i'm bored that
means i have time and options
um i think i got a better handle on on
things
because
in the in the first few years
of doing this you know when i was
replying to every comment and and having
to like keep up with requests all the
time and stuff
it was and then every time you uploaded
a video it was always like okay but
where's this yeah where's this what's
next
and doing this alone was like it was
demanding and tough and and then i
realized like there's just it's just
impossible i can never
you're never going to be able to to do
everything yeah like we're trying to set
up this other patreon website and get
other things in order and it's just
always like okay yeah where's this
where's this where's this every time we
try to explain it
you gotta sometimes you just gotta make
people wait sometimes man you just gotta
make people wait just take a few hours
everything we do it takes time yeah
patreon's finicky
popcorn happy birthday john
you being a gemini makes so much sense
definitely 100
i have looked i have looked up like what
a virgo is and i'm like i'm totally a
virgo then i don't know what you are i'm
like geminis and virgos are not the same
and you're totally a gemini yeah yeah
although i mean i don't give myself
credit very often but i guess i will say
that half the things uh said about
gemini is usually in uh
usually with a heavy sigh uh i don't as
much identify with so that's good i feel
like i'm not as like what a gemini might
say i feel like i'm not as outwardly
conniving as gemiini are often portrayed
i i don't feel like uh like i don't
delight in connivers i don't delight in
gossiping let's say and i i i
don't delight in machinations but
otherwise i'm very much what do
macadamia nuts have to do with this
get cracking man
would you ever curl your hair john sure
um yeah i mean i would be very
intimidated to do so against your
natural luscious locks i don't know if i
would ever get a perm or something like
that but i try it out see what it looks
like i should wear this as a thor loving
thunder premiere you should you could
wear that fez anywhere it looks good on
you
because then look if you wore it with
like your marvel chic outfit and and
stuff oh i got my strongest avenger hat
i should wear that to the premiere you
absolutely should wear that to the bed
it's actually the perfect hat to wear
but any other premiere you could wear
that fez and look very distinguished and
i'll wear a batman shirt
you should do that
you should absolutely do that i
sincerely have a shirt that says warner
brothers rules you should wear a shirt
from like a dark horse comics property
and just throw everyone for a loop let's
just be like wait a minute this is
obscure
uh don't worry greg you'll become old
enough to be praised like him i know you
got to respect your senior citizens
right yes 45 years old and i'm early on
the aarp do you guys get your hair in
your mouth i do it's so annoying john
you must you must get your hair in your
mouth from time to time yeah yeah i mean
that's the thing is you grow your hair
this long and like i'm sure anybody
i'm gonna say like most women out there
but i'm sure like anybody who's just
grown up with long hair yeah it's
there's a whole learning curve where you
have to learn how not to eat it or how
not to get it in everything
um
yeah john do you want to explain your
tooth you're getting a couple questions
about that in the chat sure you want the
real the real honest to goodness answer
should i keep inflating the mythos
um
no you mean you you can't
it's only fun to inflate the mythos if
you if you don't reveal that you're
going to inflate the mythos yeah yeah i
mean i don't
i want
i got plans far beyond the boundaries of
this lifetime
so um i found a company that will
basically take a piece of you and they
they need both dna and bone matter so i
figured better what better than a tooth
they take that they grind it down and
they uh extract your genetic
information from there and thus can use
that for various uh life perpetuating
treatments so i sacrificed the center
one just because symmetry they were like
we could take one in the back i'm like
that's going to mess up my chewing game
and i can't uh you know have mastication
problems so uh you know it's easy straw
access to
so
yeah that's impressive i mean yeah you
got a killer deal out of it though i did
it only cost me 45 dollars oh that you
got charged for that i thought they paid
you to do that
that's crazy i got ripped off i guess oh
man why did did they pay you
yeah what did you give up
my third nipple damn it that was so
unique it was such a part of my identity
i know that's how i came up with nipple
chills i know because i could really
feel this it was the chilliest it was
the chilliest that's why sometimes you
would see me go nipple chills
and then
like why did she touch the center
because i had a third nipple he's got a
big mono nip in the middle
it was like it's like a crater i want to
get a gold tooth i want to go i want to
be eventually i don't i haven't earned
it yet in this life so uh whatever goes
in that gap will be a tooth colored
tooth but someday i want to get just a i
want to be a one gold tooth guy
uh one of these days when i'm when i'm
like way more on top of life i'll start
getting tattoos and i'll get a gold
tooth less teeth just means more room to
store food that's right right in the
center
right up front
uh jamal
said it was a nubbin friend's reference
[Music]
never lose your nerd um third nipples do
exist i'm sure
there's got to be
there's got to be
i thought you were going to go looking
for a third one
it's behind the computer i didn't know
we could find it they didn't take it yet
you need to get your your dna
right alba cut john humphrey's long hair
no no no no no john's hair is like
jackie chan and shanghai noon you don't
want to cut that [ __ ] yeah i'll yeah
cause then i'll have to drop to my knees
and contemplate the entirety of my life
i can't return to the forbidden kingdom
anymore
you know
but uh i'll trim it at some point anyway
jamal simmons
happy birthday john
where's the punch guy okay we got you
but good the punch is coming the punch
is coming minute maid miguel leger
leisure uh
happy
bomb day bomb day or is that another
born damn i'm gonna assume that's
another born day all right he says
happythebomb.com day john we read this
one they gotta replace amber heard
that's right
guys they shouldn't replace amber
herbert cinematic universe
all of her many roles uh this is the one
thing i'll say for amber heard is as is
is is credit where it's due everybody
who's been following this trial in this
case they're like oh man amber hurts
such a shitty actress i usually think
amber heard's pretty good actress other
than that uh you know like i don't like
her that much in aquaman i agree that
role could have been filled by anybody
but i've seen her in other movies where
i'm like fine performances
do you good humans do you want to get us
under a million subscribers yeah don't
you ever talk about another good word
when we get to about amber ever
dip underneath a million we have the
road to a million to look forward to
dare you express your honest opinion
that i genuinely do not share with you
because i was saying i was listening to
campia the other day and and a shock of
all shocks he was like
i think she's a good actress
and i was like you're the first other
person i've heard admit to that because
up until this all happened
until aquaman what have i liked her i
don't know what i've liked her in that's
fine you don't have to
i know she's in that
uh drive angry movie but that's like the
only other thing i've seen her in that i
was like yeah
all the boys love mandy lane and things
like that she was in john carpenter's
last movie right she was in the ward she
was the star of the ward yeah i'll do a
reaction to that that'll go over well we
should do his johnny depp reaction amber
reaction
amber
i would have fun doing that that's about
the most fun i can culminate with the
rum diary
yes it's perfect perfect and then aren't
they don't they appear in another movie
post that together
yes we made a cameo in that one movie
that made no money and got terrible
reviews was it london fields yes yes yes
yes
that's about the only way i would want
to cover this any longer the trial is we
will communicate
all their movies
the most disproportionate back and forth
because amber heard has way less credits
john's birthday we'll give him a pass
i don't know everybody lost their minds
around that did you guys hear about the
extended edition of spider-man known way
home yes we're planning on watching it
uh reacting to it here we're gonna react
to it release the score says he cut but
depending if we don't really have a
reaction to those extended scenes we're
just gonna we're just gonna feature the
moments in the reaction the scenes
you've already seen a billion times yeah
that's a good way to do it but we'll
still title it extended cut reaction
yeah and we'll talk about those because
we reacted to that copy yeah it still
counts you could still do the watch
along over patreon uh it's dante someone
gave y'all a hundred uh someone gave
y'all
a hundred dollars super chat well thank
you why'd you only give two thank you
for giving
let us know about that
i appreciate the if everybody could send
a super chat letting us know that
somebody else sent a super chat i think
that would be the perfect scenario for
this omni media's back john
watch the x-files all one
you remember to go away from the mic i
have been watching singers lately
i was one of the times you screaming to
the mic i know
i was watching an
uh uh live performance of a song and uh
and yeah there's a bellowing portion and
i watched the way he pulled that mic
away and i was like i should learn a
thing or two from greg's advice and your
visuals like you started yelling i
looked over to see if you were away from
the mic i was like oh he's away from the
mic
good lesson learned johnny all 11
seasons and both movies tonight
side note
serious note uh think
you'd think you'd love it thank you omni
i appreciate that uh yeah at some point
i will check out the x-files
um i will absolutely yes
okay copy that not yet but i do want to
chat together a hidden memo john you
should watch the x-files man i will on
freaking team one thousand man robert
patrick no i love robert patrick so good
in every all 11 seasons robert tonight i
think david duchovny came in at the last
season definitely
they were like we need to sex this thing
up
let's get david to go let's get sex
addict david duchovny on the case when
we started californication i was like
dude company really
and then i found out like oh damn
apparently a lot of people think this
guy's like super [ __ ] sexy i had no
idea apparently this show is like
semi-biographical i had no idea that
david company was like a [ __ ] sex
item here man yeah oh i'm gonna have to
fix this chair later uh jack beaumont
happy birthday dude 45
whatever you're doing fair play thoughts
on
fair play man
fair play oh my goodness i'm going to
lean in really quick
i got you man if you can read it let me
know i'll help you out
casting i want to know because because
we i was just talking about this the
other day and i didn't know the guy's
name
casting is the 14th doctor plus neil
patrick harris as the villain looking
forward to seeing that in 2045.
neil patrick harris is the vil what we
get through doctor who relatively quick
though there's only like 10 episodes a
season sometimes less
yeah
see series eight was 13 plus the
christmas episode yeah there's only 13
episodes but no i mean but no because
like
because like psych seasons are 15 16
episodes like that there's something
that feels shorter when you have
it's weird it's like
six to ten episode series feel like one
unit and then 23 episode seasons feel
like their own thing and then shows like
doctor who or psych that are in the
middle that have like 13 to 15 episodes
they always feel like they go by the
fastest yeah definitely it's weird but
um
yeah i i
yeah i don't know if this neil patrick
harris thing is uh is is real but uh i
mean i'm i'm excited to see uh where is
the villain in um it's just when neil
patrick hasn't played villain he plays a
villain exactly how you'd expect patrick
harris to play it though he does play a
mustache twirler he does play like a
nefari a nefarious character yeah
there's always the note yeah um but uh
no i'm super excited to see uh what
nikooti got what brings to this i don't
know i i i've probably seen him before
and i just don't uh know his filmog very
much but i'm excited i mean
you know i'm sure someone out there is
is pitching a fit over there being a
black doctor
after there was a lady doctor oh my god
they did it they did the black doctor
hell yeah rwandan born scottish actor
hell yeah oh and a skut got another skut
yeah see he's been on doctor who in the
past are there people flipping out about
it um i haven't i haven't read people
flipping out about it i just know enough
to assume but i would love to be proven
wrong he's done a few things including
sex education's one i've heard of the
most i've not seen knowingly any of this
guy's performances but i feel like and i
haven't seen jodie whitaker either we're
up to peter capaldi and i'm curious to
see how jody whittaker plays the doctor
because up until now you know it's like
once you
i imagine every new whovian goes through
that process of like okay
each new doctor is
probably has aspects where you're like
oh i'm resistant at first but then oh i
really grew to love them so i've grown
to trust their casting for the doctor
i've heard mixed things about jody
whittaker's episodes as episodes but
that her casting was really good and
that she brings a lot of presents so i i
have a lot of faith and i'm really
excited to see like i always appreciate
a fresh new face and seeing a new talent
or somebody i'm unfamiliar with and uh
yeah i'm all for it let's do it i'm
excited to see
i mean i feel like it's less distracting
with a black guy than a woman sometimes
but in this case
yeah because i mean you know the history
of doctors has always been predominant
all male yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure i
can see that yeah
um i mean it does draw like a lot of
attention when you when you switch the
gender yeah it's like yes this is a
different show yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and but i'm open to it we
haven't gotten there yet but i'm not i'm
not like opposed to it yeah but i
imagine it is a bit of
reagent change yeah but i'm far like i
think that's i think doctor who of all
things lens it's like
i get how there's a harder debate around
female james bond versus female doctor
who because you know doctor who you have
that built in where it's like well
there's no saying he couldn't come back
as a woman
yeah um but yeah rhett proctor
holy crap john is 45 it's the truth
uh he doesn't look a day over 30.
they're just being nice john they know
you look your age i know happy leaf
eriksen day hinga dinga dergan lol
spongebob reference happy birthday john
spongebob reference right back i
completed it
john was the buds i remember one time in
school because john was like an avid um
editor he edited on avid since then
third grade uh john was an avid
spongebob fan it was and he
he uh there was
you know
the chant is spongebob squarepants but
no one knew all the lyrics
and someone someone broke into who lives
in a pineapple under the sea and the
class started going spongebob
squarepants and john was the only one
who was able to do the actual lyrics in
between chanting spongebob do you
remember this at all vaguely yeah you
would do all the lyrics and then we all
go spongebob it was it was cool yeah i
committed that yeah i definitely
committed that yeah man you know what
you're doing i was i was all i was here
like spongebob was one of those moments
where as a child i was like i am aware
this is coming i am anticipating the
premiere day i am there for the premiere
and yeah i am a fan
and uh yeah big love for the spongebob
thank you rhett proctor
uh for the bob love gala ghost
i got a bolt to head back to work
cheers and hope for the best birthday
yet p.s still want that giant list of
insane things coy says at parties
oh it's too long it's too long just just
follow us around to premiere someday and
you'll see him in action and your head
will swim just as much as mine
uh and
katrin
england i think happy birthday what is
the old movie or show that you guys love
that you will watch uh when you have the
chance
that you still watch when you have the
chance ooh
old movie or show you still rewatch when
you have the chance
how old are we talking just not recent
just like not within the past five years
old
if we're talking old old i really like
watching the godfather one and two i'm
always down to watch the godfather
um
yeah i'm super into those movies uh
goodfellas
like i really grew up on the like the
italian gangster films like those those
are my jam and since uh since i was like
i must have been like 12 i think when i
really started getting into them yeah so
those were those are like the the old
ones i get into like pacino de niro days
where that was like what i really
absorbed growing up yeah that's a good
call um
man i guess i would go a combo answer
uh because
one of my favorite old shows also uh
pulls old movies and mystery science
theater is definitely just something
where like there are episodes there are
specific movies that they've done that i
would just throw on if i'm just like
trying to have a fun time and enjoy
myself or maybe i'm doing something too
uh yeah revisiting that show and and
various movies through there like uh i
don't know i accuse my parents or
or bloodlust or things like that
people always compare us to them
i mean what we do is very similar i mean
we are
we don't write them the same way but you
know we're essentially riffing
we're essentially doing we riff with
care riffing with care we wait for the
characters not to talk
in shows you know and we also don't do
it to the point where it's going to
emotionally pull us out yeah wherever
their whole thing is completely taking
the piss out of whatever they're
watching yeah yeah yeah there's they
they try to keep down the crosstalk but
yeah it's all about just like let's just
kind of roast and make fun and yeah
whereas ours kind of broached the gap
between riffing and commentary when
people want like an actual reaction to
do yeah you gotta like you gotta be
emotionally invested yeah yeah yeah i
mean those are built off of watching the
movies multiple times yeah then you know
you've got you know certain improvs
certain written jokes blah blah whereas
yeah the whole charm here is it's the
first time so it's a little bit
everything
um but yeah that in the heat of the
night is a great there's a lot of old
movies that we pull out for either
halloween or christmas to like house on
haunted hill or or you know meet me and
saint louis true true king of the hill
is my favorite show that i'll go back to
i absolutely adore
mark leach happy birthday what's a top
nostalgic film for you guys
ooh
the pagemaster makes me nostalgic i
haven't seen that in years
with macaulay culkin and various
somewhat groundbreaking effects uh
god i don't know
pagemaster is a great call thanks
i used to love love love that man i used
to pretend i was getting chased by the
ink in the library
my nostalgia films are like scream
sure
yeah scream in the crow
nice
uh
warren's like check your email
we're live streaming right now
i love
where is he he's not in the back right
now i was gonna say like since
cosmic want to rent out the back house
here since he's been here more i keep
wondering like well how does that work
how does that work
just like check out the live like i
can't tell i'm doing a live stream like
i've seen the frequency at which you
guys communicate under normal
circumstances so now i'm like do you
guys text as much now that he just is
back there or or is it or does he poke
his head through the back door and he's
like hey he says he's watching the live
stream right now
i'm like how does this work how does
this update your dynamics
uh it says we can make them a mod to
delete all those accounts that are for
the naked chicks and i told them no we
need those we look like people are
attracted to us we need to look like
we're on the real internet and it's not
the real internet until someone's
advertising
pills or porn
captain kirk hey john happy birthday
what's one character from the dc or
marvel
from dc or marvel you would like to be
announced by your favorite actor actress
ooh
ooh
i'm just praying for a richard jenkins
casting
i'm sure jacobs would be a good alfred
he would be a good alfred or a good
beast
um yeah probably
[Music]
that's my answer for right now i mean
there's so many great castings it's it's
more about actors i would want to see
like yeah it's like if we could get that
keanu reeves
silver surfer i don't love the silver
surfer as much as like a ghost writer
but like you know i would love a key
honors i want i want nick cage to come
back i want them to find a way to put
nick cage in one of these uh universes
now that they're
well now the marvel universe is fully
legitimized and maybe as the dc universe
re-legitimizes itself however that goes
i just want nick cage i want it
uh i i think he would be the
chad is still about your age
you've created a monster out of the
truth
out of absolutely true information about
my real age the most common things that
i
talk about with everyone on that i know
through this platform
either me talking to them about
something i'm experiencing or something
they're experiencing the most common
thing
is
um a joke or a sarcastic thing or
something satirical completely flying
over people's heads
that's like my favorite my absolute
favorite thing is how we we're getting
so much crap for things all the time
we're like no we were we were definitely
joking we've seen toy story you know
like that's definitely seen toys i was
like i thought we made this pretty clear
but for the love of you got to really
clarify nowadays when you're just making
a joke then again it is a text i know
there's no
you don't look you don't look 45
expressions yeah yeah thanks that's
that's great
thinking you are making an obvious joke
you've actually misled everyone yeah
it must be plausible enough to where
people are like you don't look it but i
guess i guess i could see it now that i
think about it so far-fetched it's
unacceptable to me
uh so yes also thank you sane girl in
the chat uh apparently i share a
birthday with kendrick
johnny depp prince marilyn monroe and
angelina jolie so that's good company
gino's birthday was a few days ago i
know i'm sorry for stealing his thunder
i apologize
for taking focus away
from johnny depp yeah
dk happy birthday just got my thor
tickets in 4dx
to our announcement i mean amusement
park ride yes an hour and 59-minute
music i'm very excited for i got imax
tickets for it we are going to the
premiere of it too
we're going to see it so much because we
have to do a live stream you know i like
to watch it at minimum twice a minimum
six times minimum six times so that way
i don't want to talk about it because
i'm sick
i hate this movie that we can talk so
bored of this film now please don't put
me on a live stream to talk about it now
especially with coy who's gonna want to
talk a lot yeah who's who listens only
for the time when he knows he can talk
again
corey will have to like direct his whole
body to you
i love i but i feel so heard when i get
the coi
when i get the coileen yeah that's sort
of like i have full attention yeah yeah
and i love like the body shift that
comes with that it's beautiful yeah i
see his mouth
i want to talk
that's where i got this hat from yeah
happy birthday john
sent a brief photo and video on the
twitter i will check it's provocative
oh
yeah yeah
david gandy photogrammy david
i want you to meet my goliath
let's play that game where you stab
through your fingers bishop's knife
trick
yeah yeah oh i was trying to come up
with a with a joke about stella like a
ball joke but about stones because david
and goliath and the stone but you know
why i really have to go there i do yeah
i do yeah because i'm not going to get
that rock soft joke
going uh louis berry happy birthday john
thank you david and thank you again for
we're shooting on the camera that you
sent us and the lens that you sent us
and uh and i am so excited
at some point when there's a little bit
more excess time i really want to go
through all those lenses and that uh
that rig like you've been so generous
with all the camera stuff and and that
brings uh
a visual nerd like me's heart joy um
happy birthday john louis berry hope bcs
for drama
wait hope
bc is for drama bob jonathan tony ria
patrick
wait i'm missing a key piece of context
which bc what's bc
british columbia i'm pretty sure that is
better call saul that's bob owen kirk
jonathan banks
tony
i forgot his name rio horn and patrick
fabian yes okay patrick fabian
underrated actor yeah uh hey
who better call
that css you didn't yeah
freaking amazing i was like bob jonathan
now bob baby bear calls all of them yeah
another show i'm really excited to catch
up on at some point i've seen the first
season and i really liked it
i love better call saul and no i will
not react to it on this channel for
everyone who keeps asking me to but it's
the perfect reaction show greg yeah slow
deliberate drama oh deliberately people
[ __ ] every week about it's not getting
to the point yet
that's the point
brand that's not happening twice for
this season and people bitching about it
i'm like guys it's better call saul well
we'll understand whatever because
because the writing event scale the
writing of not just vince gilligan the
uh peter gold the things
um
their writing style is so much about not
they just throw you into the
conversation without ex doing setup for
the audience so you have to figure out
like what is this thing they're building
what is this third thing they're talking
about what is this thing they're
planning yeah and you don't really know
for a while
so people often get like frustrated with
the show wanting to know where it's
going
i can see that people
i i bet there's a i mean it's the
obvious thing to say but i bet there's a
pressure from people who are like why
isn't it more like breaking bad where
like the character [ __ ] and the crazy
developments are gets intense man
it gets super duper intense like it gets
really intense i really i really love
that show dude it sounds intense
yeah yeah if there was a word i used to
describe it i would say i would say
pretty intense bro uh john's keep going
i'm trying someone's got therapy in 23
minutes brian o'neill singleton wb needs
two hours will
needs to hire will to slap some sense
into ezra
that'll slap the flash deadshot slaps
the flash deadshot slaps the flash dude
that will go viral and i mean that i
feel like if yeah if we could repurpose
the slapping to a disciplinary thing
where it's just like if you don't fall
in line we're going to send will smith
to your plays
keep everyone in hawaii's name out your
[ __ ] mouth uh right thank you very
much
rhett proctor
also do you guys think thor love and
thunder will be too short i'm still
excited but concerned uh the story might
be rushed no because taika ytd style
multiverse of madness had me concerned
from the get-go when i heard that
because
there's like a gazillion
things they were setting up in a whole
new like the door 11 thunders it's the
fourth installment there's a lot of
familiarity with the way who these
characters are already and
you know like him traveling through
worlds and universes is not it's like
something we're already familiar with
thor
yeah and it's taika white td who already
has a fast rhythm
and and has already mastered that so
it seems appropriate to me yeah to me
i'm like not too early i'm not bothered
by
at all by it right around two hours is
like yeah you know give or take five ten
minutes yeah i'm sure it's yeah it's
fine sure fine
if it was like an hour and a half i
would be like
yeah yeah
hour and 45 i was like maybe a little
short but yeah like two hours good two
hours good
uh alex marta
happy birthday john hope y'all done a
moo have you all done a movie and 4dx
seeing lightyear that way we have we
have we've done 40x we've done 40 i used
to do 40x all the time before covered we
were doing 40x all the time yeah we were
doing 40x we just did d-box this past
week and a friend of mine asked me over
the weekend what's the difference and i
would say
you know if you want the universal
studios ride version where you got stuff
coming at you that's a 4dx experience
but if you want like top gun i feel like
top gun was perfect in d-box because
that's like
i almost feel like you could use all the
extra effects but all you need is that
rumble all you need is that rumble to
feel like you're in the cockpit
yeah sometimes 40x can be
depending on the movie a bit much
yeah it's like if it's jurassic world or
something like that like which great
infor in d-box grade and d-box that's a
bigger
vote of confidence in a 4-dx experience
to me where i'm like okay it's going to
be in a forest and dinosaurs you want
mist and heat and like all that stuff
you know it was a surprisingly great 40x
experience what's up
is a skyscraper the wayne johnson movie
yeah that was surprisingly really good
in 4dx when they had like the snow and
the fire and stuff out and the smoke for
that film and that was one i was like
why would i watch this in 48 and then
this is actually a really good 40x
experience yeah but sometimes the
movie's already so crazy
that it just kind of becomes a little
too crazy
when you're in 40x godzilla versus kong
was a little much yes it was where
you're like i can't even keep it with
the movie and the camera's ready not
gonzales versus kong uh king of the
monsters yeah uh king of the monsters
was like oh my god there's already i
can't i can't tell what the [ __ ] going
on on the street and now i'm just like
jumping around this whole theater now
see that's a situation where if i i
would go like a d-box where i'm like
okay maybe a little bit of enhancement
but not too much but certain movies
it's like yeah godzilla king of the
monsters or godzilla vs kong is like
it's already a universal studios ride or
something like skyscraper you could go
that extra mile well yeah i think i
think d-box is great for because what
all they're doing is they're mirroring
the camera movement so you're moving
with the camera yeah and they're and
they're translating any vibrations or
haptic motions yeah yeah so i like i
like d-box a lot um i thought especially
on top gun that was awesome
yeah was awesome and like you said it's
that perfect balance it's like i feel
like you could utilize all the effects
of a 40x for top gun but wait are they
paying us right now to talk about it
right here
i'm trying to spread it around in case
40x and d-box want to pay us
if they're not paying us to talk about
this right now then i don't think we
should recommend it don't go see movies
caitlyn martinez thank you for the super
stickers
very lovely i'm going to lean in fast
little sunglass guy i like it uh
caitlyn martinez follow-up wow 45th
really well congrats you're looking
great for 45 john that's my thing all
the time at john here timer john
i'm gonna kick the bucket soon there
ain't you johnny old man humphrey old
man logan jj doe john johnny doe
no no wait wait
jay slayer sawyer jay sawyer
everyone gets a cool misread name today
jay sawyer happy birthday john hair
looks better than ever he planned for it
baby he planned for it he said today's
the day i'll get the curls going someday
today's the day yeah man i feel like i i
used to want buzz cuts so badly as a kid
and and now i'm like i don't know if i
would ever cut my hair
shorter than you should shave your head
and grow a big beard people say that i
can't grow that well i can grow a beer
eyeliner i i've jacked i've not really
spent here i want to get more buff
i want to get at least more fit but i've
tried i haven't tried for years but you
know like i don't know if i grow like a
big beard really like i don't know if i
could grow like a foot long of a beard
uh so that's a that's you know a
handicap there
uh
i shaved my head i just don't think it
would look good i think my head's the
wrong shape i feel like it would be too
dude you should shave your head
i someday i think it'd be a challenge
it would be a challenge to still get
them to still get the ladies huh
can john still pick up chicks even with
a shave head without letting my hair do
a hundred percent of the work for me hey
doesn't do a hundred percent i'd say
it's fifty
shall accept it i'll say 70 and meet you
in the middle
it's not reader 50s meeting me
i'll meet you between 70 and 100 or 50
and 175 no man shave your head try it
out okay please on camera i'll pay five
dollars if we get to two million
subscribers in a week i'll shave it
what if that was the thing and then we
do and i'm like damn it
other channels have made their channels
about johnny depp amber heard we'll make
our channel about john shaving his head
that'll go over just as well
and it'll just be me spouting off
videos about you being having a shaved
head
shaving my head and just talking about
amber heard performances i thought were
pretty decent despite her legal woes and
public image
corey hermann happy birthday john
looking good for 45. oh yeah thank you
so much you guys are making my
legitimate 45th birthday feel so much
better it almost feels
like a 30-something birthday if i wasn't
uh wearing my glasses poven-meyer
it's chris correct have you been on
drama alert what the [ __ ] would i ever
go on goddamn trouble what is it no
don't well i mean you would be a good
commentator
i just make a bunch of sarcastic
comments yeah you should take like this
is [ __ ] stupid we're on youtube yeah
we should just be making our own
yeah like
rather than feeding
convo what do i care about this
this is stupid we're on youtube
that's a that's the ultimate symbiotic
there's real there's real drama out
there people there's there's a whole war
in russia that people seem to have
completely forgotten about
you know once it wears out in terms of
being like the most interesting thing in
the news cycle
i mean there's a war but
amber her giant trial happened that's
way closer that's way more interesting
all right i can relate way bigger than
that i've seen this guy's movie
hey man zielinski is an actor
he's been in stuff
uh but yes if you can give some support
to the folks in ukraine do do that as
well
hey popenmeier it's chris evans and tim
allen's birthday today it's also tim
allen's birthday how wild crazy happy
buzz day happy buzz lightyear to
everybody it's funny because tim allen's
such a republican chris evans is such a
liberal liberal yeah and they're both
playing buzz lightyear and one was at
the premiere and the other wasn't how
crazy i've been tim allen showed up i
know they invited his ass i don't think
so i i wanted i was curiou well i won't
say anything about the movie itself but
i yeah i was i was surprised that there
was no presence yeah man yeah you know
it's okay maybe they'll do a spin-off or
a multiverse movie where toy buzz meets
real buzz
and then uh he faints i mean credit to
tim allen man his his uh [ __ ] this
buzz lightyear voice i think it's
you just hear the voice of buzz
lightyear that was like perfect pixar
just knocked it out of the park their
first go around didn't they yeah he's
[ __ ] made toy stories
it was like perfect classic perfect
instant classic and then the voice
casting was perfect like you're not even
thinking of tom hanks and tim allen when
you're watching that [ __ ] no
like their voices are so perfect for
those characters yeah it's really well
cast her supporting cast is is perfectly
chosen too like great character actors
and they're all toy story movies
underrated
i think people forget how perfect of a
of a debut for pixar that was for a
feature film yeah oh yeah i feel like
toy story the franchise gets its love
but but people talking about how much of
a game changer the original movie yeah
yeah because yeah i don't even think of
tim allen i think of buzz lightyear no
he's just buzz lightyear but he's got
the perfect voice he's got the perfect
performance for it yeah because tim
allen personality and the home
improvement personality he's not the
same as buzz lightyear at all no no he
does do a great job as buzz and i mean
you know he's using a lot of his own
voice but he's also doing a bit of a
voice and i appreciate that too yeah
even woody is pretty close to tom hanks
even though i'm not like thinking as
much about him he's got that loud
nasally tom hanks thing going on yeah
it's like tom hanks but like more manic
yeah you know is what i associate woody
dorian duck
uh yeah we got papa mardovian duck no
effin way john is 45. you better believe
it [ __ ] what's your secret are
you drinking baby blood with tom cruise
i am i am that's the way you get in with
tom you know it's actually it's really
easy to meet him it's really easy to
become his friend you just got to take
that plunge you know and next week i'll
be flying planes dude tom cruise on me
drink baby blood i do it
no in a heartbeat i do anything tom
cruise asked me to do respect the blood
for interview with the vampire we drank
real blood
[Laughter]
i am undergoing a process of immortality
never aging
yeah
aren't they making a show do i become a
vampire
i talk to all the most i talk to all the
real vampires i've talked to chris
mccory about how do i sink my banks to
people's necks efficiently
efficiently but with conviction
i i want it i want more tom cruise vamp
action jj doe okay
question for john
if you could have sam and dean
winchester fight monsters
in one of these shows which would it be
zombies in the walk of dead
white walkers and game of thrones or the
mind flayer and the demogorgons and
stranger things oh
stranger things would easily be the most
fun and i think it would also play into
the references that sam and dean
especially
uh like to make already
walking dead
i don't know if that would make the show
it wouldn't make the show worse i think
they'd be perfect for stranger things
they would be perfect for stranger
things like game of thrones white walker
i would watch that but i would also feel
like this is a little too much i'm also
like the 80s rock and roll yeah yeah
absolutely yeah yeah and the variety of
supernatural monsters you got to deal
with yeah so it's like you would have
the fun of them going up against
something that isn't the canon of
supernatural creatures you're familiar
with plus it's the perfect place for
their pop culture sensibilities yeah oh
a thousand percent yeah stranger things
it's absolutely stranger things no
contest why would you even ask and you
know like sam and dean not wanting to
work with kids
being annoyed and frustrated with them
yeah dean yeah begrudgingly warming up
to dustin yeah no i think it'd be
perfect being like steve harrington
yeah i'm for it i think stranger things
is definitely absolutely the one
all right we are gonna do one more pass
through all these but for right now i'm
just fair warning we're gonna close
the soups i mean you might be able to
stay here longer
i will sit here and
don't catch up on any other work today
john no
i will not prepare psych for tomorrow
i will not update the podcast i will not
talk to the web designer we are trying
to get a lot going right now i will not
do any product placements i will not
shoot hunter hunter koi's going out of
town for a couple weeks we're trying to
shoot more
these last couple of videos with koi i'm
off to the side and i'm like have a
laptop on and i'm like making notes the
whole time and yeah thinking like what
inserts i got to gather the whole time
for the edits
i'm often interrupting him being like no
no
i did while john's loading this i'll
tell you a fun story about koi we did a
list video
about um upcoming dc
dc movies and he had he was like we
should go for like an even 20. right
because we only had 19. he's like i
think there's a 20th movie out there i
was like okay fine we'll find that 20th
we'll be fine and we found it it was
like an actual one that's been in
development and uh
there's 20 movies keep in mind and it's
because it's coy yes
and we got to uh
we got to number four on the list
and then i had to argue 20 minutes i had
to interrupt him and be like coy look we
got 20 of these to go through we got
this has to be edited
we're at 13 minutes right now
you can't just
start
you understand you filming does not take
as long as this being edited yes
like you are the most important part of
this video undoubtedly you are the thing
that is bringing the vital information
and the personality and the energy you
are the most essential part but it's
gonna take a long time to edit this but
however yeah we we gotta be able to get
people to watch this
yeah oh but that was so fun to listen to
through the wall even like i was
prepping footage and i just heard like
just these occasional cascades of
uproarious laughter oh you said some
stupid [ __ ] that will not be in the
video
there's a couple of things you said that
right you've won
so funny i could think of it but it was
such a mistake it's such a it was like
he didn't he just didn't realize what he
would he read
roam burgundy him a couple of times oh
i'll help him out with notes ron
burgundy
all righty let's check the last of the
stream lubs
let's do
do do do go through i think we were
caught up aren't we no no dude we caught
up oh damn i gotta jump ship in like
eight minutes i know can i trust you to
learn how to end something i know
i mean i could just end it once i get
through the super chats don't worry
cause i'll be concerned then about
wasting time here so it'll be okay
uh i'll i'll be stressed about something
different so so that'll keep me in check
because people are here to show you love
i know and i just want to sit here all
day and enjoy it like because especially
i mean you know times have been busy and
and of all like i'm not the best at
celebrating my own birthday but
especially this year hasn't really been
conducive to like let i don't have a
party like you know so this is kind of a
party and and i appreciate it very much
yeah man it's making my birthday feel
more birthday-like look how much they
love you i know i'm so honored i love
you guys you guys women ever accused you
of domestic violence
and then you went to trial the
defamation you would have all these
people supporting you
right thank you all
and i thank you all just make sure she's
a nobody yeah yes
support me no matter what i do even if
it's
actually terrible
did i read that correctly yes you did
sir
john
phleb doran says what happened to
you and julia ra i'm just going to read
this over here what happened to you and
julia rose you said that you are meant
to be together when i searched your name
on famous birthdays there's a 30 year
old reality star with the same name
wait a minute i think he's saying
there's another john humphrey there's a
john humphrey who's a reality star and
who's 30. that's right there's john
humphrey bigger than you out there man
wow
wow this man is your enemy who's julia
rose though oh dude julie rose is hot
okay unless she's under age i have no
idea who she is uh i just googled julia
rose i have no idea who she is
uh i'm assuming she's this girl with
jake paul paul okay
ah she actually is pretty attractive
okay
i was kind of hoping for like a [ __ ]
funny photo of her yes
what happened to you and julia rose well
you know uh jake paul is just someone i
can't compete with you know man [ __ ]
jake paul put me on drama alert i'm
sitting here
let's talk about this [ __ ] i'm just
sitting here going to myself i'm missing
is something flying over my head here
anyway uh yeah imagine being those paul
brothers [ __ ] filthy rich
young age
no
[ __ ] logan paul riding off jake
paul's fame they just
leave little trails of money wherever
they go
you just follow them around oh gosh so
rich so much money
yeah man they don't the rules don't
apply anymore logan paul doing videos
crying over the fact that he didn't buy
real pokemon cards for a million dollars
man what a real weird problem
i know i'm too rich guys can you watch
this video hopefully the adsense covers
my loss here it's like wait so what if
these are real pokemon cards were you
not going to do a video
yeah you're just going to have like a
million dollars worth of pokemon cards
absolutely that's yeah yeah no totally
now he's got to make it back because he
doesn't even have the pokemon card
there's no exchange
of money for goods here
yeah it is i mean yeah that's that's
that's how you know you got too much
money that's your problem like oh [ __ ] i
feel bad for you dude
do i i'm sorry you got duped on your
pokemon fandom so much money to spend on
pokemon cards yeah man hey the plight of
the the rich and famous
flev says also glad to hear you're going
back to demon slayer you can go right
into season two because the first part
of the season
is the movie split into seven episodes
is it really so i don't
have to watch mogan train as its own
movie no do that why would you do that
to people
i feel like i should watch the movie but
if i watch the movie so if i watch the
movie then i could just skip seven
episodes ahead yeah okay well either way
it'll get seen either way i'll be using
a movie man i feel like i should watch
it in movie format because the movie was
such a big deal yeah man um but anyhow
yeah man
yeah say hi to your mother for me if i
was a tuna
you if i would you were a tuna and i was
lying
is that the other guys yeah yeah
yeah watch first off lions can't swim
that's a great [ __ ] [ __ ] that's a
funny ass [ __ ]
funny motion picture event of the summer
all right we are close we are close don
and duck we got dolan duck we got the
same therapist
they're going to be like where are you
you're getting charged you if you need
to leave oh i got charged for the one i
missed last week oh you did yes i moved
it to four different days and then
ultimately was like these are all nights
sorry
uh in fact i still gotta reschedule the
one for this week happy birthday again
mark leach says have either of you
watched the fear street trilogy i have
not yet i'm dying to see it people were
doing reactions at the time so i think i
held off in case that were to happen but
now i just gotta find a good time to do
it if not would it be something you'd
react to
i had so much fun with them i don't know
is it is it still viable or not so much
i feel like it's probably not viable i
don't know i had never seen forrest gump
so i said i'll watch it and it got two
hundred thousand views so who knows
maybe but that's an american movie
classic that's a little different than
the fierce
like oh [ __ ] people are watching this
forest guppy reaction it's a little
different than rl stein but but i get
you
uh and maybe i would like to see them at
the very least i'll say something if i
end up watching that i mean it meets the
criteria that we're interested in it
yeah there's a lot of things that we
don't do that we know like we could have
done the johnny depp amber trial to
death we could have [ __ ] up oh why
didn't we watch the house dragons
trailer but i'm not particularly
interested in house of dragons right now
oh
game of thrones without source material
is a dubious proposal i'm not i'm not
entirely interested in housing i'll wait
that's what i haven't covered anything
i'll wait to see if they actually have
something great to go off of with that
eric c some people will like any channel
you only do things for views i'm like no
we like we like them to get views but we
also like to be interested in at first
too
yeah and house of dragons ain't doing it
for us right now the ideal the ideal
blend is yeah it's like this might get
smiles on it and i would like to check
it out that's the perfect blend yeah
that's exactly what that's what
everything everywhere all at once is for
me right now yeah eric c thank you for
the on set director chair i love it i
appreciate it i wish these stickers were
real and i could put them on something
but i like digital too it's auntie harry
styles is a fourth nipple does he really
dude he is he's the king of nipple
chills then
you gotta fight harry styles now
for the title [ __ ] for title of nip of
chilly nip king dude i hear herself as a
charming ass [ __ ] i know
harry's house out now
he's on tour we should go see him live
stream it react to it
monetize monetizable life experiences
get kicked out for recording and
broadcasting the show
michael mack i may be delirious from
covid but i think greg said a while ago
on a stream that he was writing a horror
movie is this correct happy birthday
again john the sexiest 95 year old man
on youtube but thank you that's my real
age i got three horror movies going dude
you're the horror guy
i have one that's for the studio already
that's now that's just if they end up
freaking getting it made but it's out of
my hands now it's with the studio it's
out of my hands
second one
was going through development hell
third one that's even scary it's
actually looking pretty good right now
oh yeah that one's looking pretty good
i'm excited about that one it's been
very fun to watch this process a lot of
like crazy behind-the-scenes stuff and
you learned that oh wow no one was lying
when you hear stories of people like
taking years to get something off the
ground yeah nothing's made until it's in
a dvd box yep
yeah that's what i've learned is
it all takes many years to get one of
these stories going but i got three
going right now so [ __ ] so you can
always get more that's why i'm producing
now here
so i'm like koi i need a show i might
not be around
koi dukes comic corner for me
dance monkey let's keep the channel
alive
monkey day
for
ghost
yeah
oh it's going to be the end of an era
ghost month that's stupid
the one one of these might actually get
made and then and then it nothing then
it's not successful
like oh [ __ ] i should have kept the
channel alive
you got to keep the channel alive man
not until you're not until you're like
third
produced not until i'm kevin smith yeah
where the channel is just whenever the
[ __ ] i want to be here and then that's
what it is that's the dream that's the
dream of life
ghost monkey it's hot i do love it i
gotta be honest i do i would have a hard
time completely letting go of this i
can't see myself ever
leaving at least the producer side of
this channel that would be like
impossible for me
well yeah i mean i can't see i can't see
it being possible i i would have to
remain involved somehow yeah it can't be
i mean no shade to nerdist i like
current nerdist but you know you don't
you don't want to be that where it's
like you know you started a thing and
then it gets sold and now it's somebody
else's thing entirely to the point where
they can denounce you if they want to no
because a lot of you guys don't know is
there's always people trying to get
involved with this channel
and half the time like now you guys
don't get what this channel is the whole
point is it was supposed to constantly
feel like we're just hanging out and
sometimes they get too hyper stylized
it's like the way i talked about with
koi for koi's comic corner it's like
like it's kind of like a new rockstars
video but more casual
like off the cuff not scripted yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah a little less like okay
there's wipes and there's like a whole
bunch yeah yeah yeah it doesn't there's
inserts
yeah yeah there's inserts and [ __ ] but
it's like like i wanted koi because it's
like he hangs out we we shoot the [ __ ]
you know versus
um he's easy to talk to yeah yeah i've
always wanted i always want to maintain
that like
we're kicking it even though we're
actually assembling a video it's like
hurry
get it done it's taking hours
faster faster faster
why is the internet working
yeah why is something always broken when
we need it now oh my god views are down
how do we get these up
is there something out there that we
want to do yeah
yeah
but i love the game i do i i love the
game of you i love the game of this it's
fun
to me it's an awesome life when you're a
good player
you're a good player john it's your
birthday [ __ ] you man it's your birthday
[ __ ] you you're complimenting me
carl's jr [ __ ] you i'm eating ghost
monkey it's humphrey john humphrey
a-hole
happy b day john and congrats to you
both such a lovely friendship to aspire
to oh you have no idea squad goals you
have no idea the trouble is behind the
scenes yeah and how upset the agency
gets with us when we don't play nice he
took a [ __ ] in my master bedroom the
other day
on the bed
on the floor just like your favorite
actor is like my favorite the best
actress
amber
heard that i will not i will not play
into that have you heard the bird amber
heard my turd turd well the turd is the
worst
don't you know
because they're too busy with the
low-hanging fruit of just doing the name
you heard the turds
chris don't you know about the turd meg
everybody knows that the turd is the one
rocks reviews and reactions happy
birthday john thank you so much also did
you think we will uh
see the seconds tintin movie soon it's
been 11 years god no i don't think it's
never coming soon i almost would expect
a tintin movie to come out of like
france belgium before it comes out of
the united states of america
or someplace else i don't expect a
sequel to the spielberg uh joe cornish
edgar wright one hey coy i'm about to go
into therapy
oh koi thank you so much i got to
respond to your texts
you're a sheep did you hear us talking
[ __ ]
i
about
you
just got in there seconds ago oh good oh
camera at the right time you gave me the
right time let's make this all about you
let's make this all about talking trash
with me
hi who's that
i hear yeah the the squishing the it's
like a cartoon
i'll see you at six all right bud yay
koi day
thank you so much guys i just pinned one
of koi's comments tj perry all right
we'll see you guys tj perry's in here
all right like
tj perry from st charles pj what'd it do
oh my god it is you all right john hold
on the fort i gotta go to therapy all
right go get your head shrunk go feel
better
don't [ __ ] go yeah we're the good
ones we're the good ones and that's a
better hell bad that's a better help
advertising approved that copy yeah
they're like this is fine but could you
swear a little more when you represent
prime examples of therapy
look at us
we are functional we are happy we are
happy
damn it
if you think otherwise you're a fool
you guys can easily trick john into
staying on here for way longer than
necessary i was gonna say how much time
do i have i'm gonna try and wrap this up
in the next 20 minutes by three o'clock
i'm gonna try and wrap this up
okay
and that was honest to goodness truth
this is great i'm excited to watch the
stream numbers plummet
as as we continue along here but yes
thank you koi koi has been pinned uh
verity would love to meet you someday
it's always fun when people come up and
say what's up it's always fun to hear
what you guys are into and just i don't
know y'all everybody who's come up to us
thus far has been very enthused and very
friendly and very supportive and we
appreciate and are spoiled by that the
official oc
love to ireland happy b day posh
dario rojas if i am 45 greg is at least
you know like early 20s
that's probably correct thank you
savindu
uh godzilla
rock sheesh damn i always want to get
people's names right and i feel like i
definitely didn't there yes jj fed i
have taken over this is my live stream
this is about to become info wars
they're making the frogs gay
is what we're going to talk about now
and and yeah i bet you're really excited
to be alone and me it says the internet
uh ezra miller kidnaps a teenager and
disappears that we would be talking
about probably if that is actually the
truth kunomim no you're not 45 uh
prove it
prove it uh miguel legere yeah john's
only beyond this point this is it's like
um it's like the opposite of the no
homers club it's me it's just the only
john's club and thank you so much bagel
trails i like your name sl7 got some koi
love in here pablo the pigeon i we love
you i'm gonna swing greg's mic out of
the way i'm gonna turn the mic sound off
so that nobody uh is confused but yes oh
my god i'm gonna read a little bit of
the regular chat let's uh yes let's go
john's stream that's right that's right
i was actually only the person the only
person here this whole time greg uh was
he's like an elaborate system of pulleys
that i do with like a ventriloquist
voice technique
greg older than me
never
never he's definitely not younger than
me by three months
uh thank you so much richard brown and
rosh torres
uh what are i planning to binge eat
today
i i probably just i'll binge drink
coffee
uh i had sushi last night which is often
my celebratory meal whiskey shots
nathaniel becker i'm for it i like a
good shot i've been into um
i mean black russians are my go-to
drinks but i've been into tequila things
lately and mezcal so you know there's
that
intense shots but you know john if
you're reading this don't forget to do
other things today don't worry big mo
logan i'm gonna do so many there's never
a shortage of things to do in here
um and yes
yeah mode man we can greg's gone we can
all loosen our belts and act normal true
but what you'll find is that you will
start to miss the structure
that having your belt somewhat tight
gives you so you know appreciate
uh uh you know the tension there's good
tension to be found there right between
the loose and the rigid and i feel like
between greg and i we have a good uh
you know it boils over every now and
again but we have a good tension between
the loose and the rigid
uh hey let's do another couple super
chats here we're nearing the end
and uh i i'm not 35. anyway
here we go
we got rockin reviews reactions uh
tintin movie yeah don't don't think so
on that tintin movie unfortunately a
movie i still have to see even and i was
so excited about the pedigree nicodemus
gonna be like the gold tooth doctor from
fm from fullmetal alchemist brotherhood
no
no if i'm thinking of the right
character absolutely not
i gotta double check though there are a
lot of sinister doctors in anime i miss
that show though that is such a great
series uh full metal alchemist
brotherhood like that
people often ask like about you know
your your
not that it was it wasn't my gateway in
anime like we watched a lot of anime as
kids when toonami was on but like as far
as this stage in my life like it was
like the big thick tome i jumped into
and uh
and uh digested first and foremost on uh
the patreon page
yeah man that doctor is a sinister
character but but same idea you know but
i would want to make a good name for one
gold tooth guys because you know there's
a slippery road there and that's why i
feel like i have to earn it s hussain
happy birthday john party hard
party hard i should have worn my andrew
wk shirt that's what i should have done
i've i have a us department of partying
shirts i should have been wearing today
i didn't know i wasn't fully sure this
was going to happen so i i didn't but
yes
i appreciate
uh you coming to party
and uh keeping the party alive with me
the party never dies
and uh go listen to music is worth
living for
among other andrew wk joints
uh yeah happy birthday from canada thank
you red velvet thank you quizot
coming from you especially that means a
lot
i'm glad that the
sorry i got very caught up in in a
moment of reading that apparently the
frogs did turn gay anyway um
big mo logan with the fact checking i i
appreciate that and yes q the door is
the end mr kat dennings andrew w.k
that's right and in fact one of the
first concert tickets i bought uh when
like last year when the world seemed
like it could be opening up for the
first time
oh wow this is going so fast this chat
uh yeah i bought a ticket to andrew wk
the show wound up getting rescheduled
and then ultimately canceled so
so yeah i'm still trying to get that
inaugural concert
everyone's been playing but but
hopefully i'll catch something in
september at the very least but yes
uh criminally underrated fullmetal
outcome is absolutely
um
i've not seen the original fma but i
know some people who do prefer it
in certain ways
southern millionaire i'm not sure why
you got muted i don't think you should
have been unless you were spamming or
doing something naughty
um jj fett really glad to hear that we
make your day and thank you for rating
the podcast on spotify if anybody likes
what we do and likes our commentary if
you could go to spotify or apple podcast
or anywhere leave us a like and follow
the show there i mean it's often
sorry it's often stuff that you're going
to see in here on youtube as well but
we're growing our following there and it
does help out a lot especially with some
of you know the different brand deals
that we've had to help you know it's all
an interconnected interlocking brick
system of things but yeah like seriously
thank you for calling out the podcast
and anybody uh who's interested in
taking us in that way would love to have
you over there spotify apple podcasts uh
audible wherever wherever you get your
stuff it should be there
and thank you s hussein for the super
chat stevo gaming th i can't believe
you're 45 man you don't look a day over
30. thank you so much this makes me feel
great uh you look great man hope you're
having an awesome birthday i am it's
been very mellow it's been very chill
it's been a busy busy busy time it's
often busy in the height of summer at
the
st pre you know proto summer days uh you
know once we get into june usually
things are right jumping but yeah i feel
in the love and i appreciate it and as
much as as much as especially the past
couple weeks have been so crazy and so
busy um it's nice to kind of be here and
to to focus in on the birthday energy
for a little bit so thank you so much
stevo gaming reed coles happy birthday
john have you guys watched the other
buzzfeed unsolved videos and would you
like a collab with ryan and shane i
would adore a collab with ryan and shane
i have watched uh probably not all of
them but i've watched many uh buzzfeed
unsolved videos and they are a lot of
fun i have a lot of fun with those and
uh you know i mean
we put we bust out like paranormal stuff
around halloween time every once in a
while just to see if it's a little more
suited to our algorithm this year but um
i love spooky stuff and i love halloween
and i love uh you know
haunted things and horror movies so i
would adore any chance to collab with
those guys and do anything in a buzzfeed
unsolved vein and when we did uh patreon
request videos we don't do those anymore
but when we did the patron video
requests those were always some of the
most fun
getting sent
um so yeah we'd love more buzzfeed
unsolved anthony happy birthday man i
hope you have a great one i love your
guys content thank you so much that
means a ton we we put a lot of hard work
and effort into it we're here every day
and uh it means a lot to know that you
guys care and that you guys love the
content and
we'll do our best to keep it going keep
the maintain the utmost level of quality
i know we bring
to this stack of dollar 81 i mean how
could uh why why would nobody um
you know i i'm clearly 45. you've got to
know this oh damn coy called me too
[ __ ] a i should have called on and my
dude aaron shouts out to my dude aaron
warner from the dank ass stubs podcast a
good good lovely wonderful friend of
mine also wanted to shout out a dude i
met over the weekend
who funny enough i have seen
dance
i didn't realize when i met him because
he was wearing a mask uh but this dude
dances if you live anywhere near la
you've probably seen him dance but uh on
instagram he goes by deadpool3000
and uh he's got a bud named ebonymaw22
met those guys over the weekend i met i
i pointed out this dude i was like he's
wearing this this immortal mask with
these horns on it and i was like you you
got a crazy mask and i've seen you just
out in hollywood before um so just hey
props on you for being out here and
doing what you're doing and then he
looked at me and he was like rejects and
i was like yeah so uh and then yeah and
then i looked him up on instagram and
found that this is a guy i've seen
dancing around town for like years
before i even saw him in the mask so
yeah deadpool go give him a look anyway
anthony
happy birthday man hope you have a great
one love you guys content i read that
already but hey thank you so much yes
disney fan i am alone in the live stream
bailey
obviously i am 45. it's only the truth
and uh ghost files the watcher i i've
seen their new channel as well i i i'm
following and uh i would love to catch
up on some of those but yes mason frost
just wanted to say rudy panko as human
torch look him up real quick or watch a
scene of him on outer banks i'm speaking
it into existence all right all right
we'll do a quick check see who rudy
panko is you say panko i just started
thinking of uh of breadcrumbs
and i started thinking of fried food
rudy pankau panko he looks kind of like
harry harold styles a little bit
um
okay so this is what we got here okay i
can see it i can see it i i'm sensing an
attitude from this guy there we go ooh
looky there shirtless gotta get the
shirtless shot gotta get the shirtless
but yeah i can see it i can see it for a
human torch i can already see some of uh
the johnny blaze attitude in there but
also you know that potential for
gravitous
gravity gravitas
um
yes
sorry everyone's uh
just getting stray messages all over the
place but yes okay
good anybody else agree with that
anybody else agree with henry pankau
rudy pankow sorry
leave it in the chat who do you want to
play the human torch do you want to play
thing nobody is talking about that and
don't say chickless
uh even though chiklis is great uh hey
ari artois arto ar aerys artos
uh happy birthday from greece
really hope you guys give the dc series
the incredible dc series young justice a
chance greg wiseman who had previously
worked on spectacular spider-man has
involved with the series it's funny
somebody i was just talking to i want to
say it was ace cabrera was just talking
about young justice and how much he was
loving that finale taryn edgerton
eggerton as human torch uh yeah
i could see that too for sure we were
just talking about him coy and i on our
wolverine video uh go send that some
love if you get a mo if you get a chance
uh would very much appreciate that uh
i'm gonna try shaggy rute
reout i'm gonna i've screwed that up
holy but hello to russia and much love
to you i hope you're doing okay out
there too
the world's a crazy place and uh i i
hope that you are you guys are doing all
right as well
um so yeah
uh and yes yes jessica cowan
he's harold styles that's that's
that's the uh distinguished version and
that's for you to keep um
i don't know what's going on here block
the sex spots please i'm trying
i'm trying jiggy j don't worry i'm
putting this user in a time oot
all right
ezra miller i'm getting these reports i
guess we're gonna have to talk about
this
um use your mojo john we got fembots in
the chat i know i know i know i'm gonna
have to do my hip thing and make them
explode their brains dave batista would
have been perfect for the thing but that
ship has sailed ah yeah i can see that
poppy dior live
thank you for the moment of silence i
very much appreciate it uh aaron w
is that my dude hold on i gotta text my
dude and see if it's him
uh because yeah
holy [ __ ] dude
hold on i'm gonna start with thank you
so much man
did you send that super chat
but either way thank you for the moment
of silence if it's not you aaron i love
my buddy aaron i don't get to see him as
often as i would like and i keep hoping
that someday we can resurrect the dank
ass stubs podcast because i do have
a very deep love and and it's funny it
pops up now again and now and again in
uh
in
our little uh
oh snap
we'll call again and maybe we can end
off the live stream i can't i can't go
too long and get crazy here but if you
call again i'll say what's up um oh i
would love to be cast as micro in the
reboot uh and hey sarah latterer thank
you so much
for the happy birthday from ohio i've
been to ohio i got family out in ohio so
i got a special place in my heart for
ohio cincinnati area especially kevin
rodriguez happy birthday you party city
jesus costume look at geek
this looks like party city
really is that where we're going with i
mean you know you can get some some
decent stuff at party city but uh i i
mean i would like to think i don't look
quite as as uh
budgetary friendly as that but thank you
just the same wish uh you many more and
much love to you and four eyes next to
you that's hey you know greg looks
looks good in glasses all right i'm just
going to say that right now greg looks
good in glasses and hey
aaron w back with a happy morbid time
oh yeah i'm sending you a a morbius gif
right now um anybody who who uh yeah
leaves a morbius uh anything that's what
i want for my birthday you know just
more be a sweep
and uh yeah you just got morbed guys
so uh yeah we're gonna refresh these
chats uno mas
uh and we're gonna start wrapping it up
because it's about three o'clock it's
about time to head out it's about time
for us to move on to the rest of the day
but seriously i could hang out with you
guys here all day if i didn't think that
would get very boring for everybody
watching um but yeah oh we see john and
chris evans share birthday i know i'm so
excited
you didn't get that many texting people
on your 30-something eighth birthday
dude it's okay it's not about the amount
of text you get it's about the quality
of the love that people express to you
and i hope that at least some people
express their
gratitude for your continued existence
mode man oh oh
what's up dude you are on the line
caller number one
oh damn yeah yeah it's just me now it's
just me i'm wrapping this thing up i'm
reading the last of the chats
and uh aaron from dank ass stubs rio
rejects og
here in the chat with me
thank you for thank you for uh
supporting morbius with your super chat
by the way
you know it's like you know you gotta
give it up for the real ones the more
pets who've been on uh
day one yeah man people people who have
been riding the morbius sweep
yeah sometimes you just gotta get more
obviously a beast
that's right man
man absolutely how are you how are you
aaron warner
uh i heard of romans having a whole ass
birthday dude it's a pretty whole
birthday
it's like
it's like having 12 birthdays in one day
every birthday is today all of my
birthdays are happening at once every
birthday every day all at once
basically it's like the opposite of the
birthdays in wonderland you you have all
your birthdays on one day yeah just to
get them out of the way
yeah at the end
dude that's that's that's all we can
hope for man if i was on that benjamin
button [ __ ] i would be pleased
i would love to be staying on that
benjamin buttons yeah man it's okay you
can get there
definitely yeah yeah yeah that's a good
head cannon chat do you guys agree that
the boss baby is just benjamin button
but at the end of his life you know
finally
embracing the position he's in you know
to capitalize
yeah dude he's literally working himself
into an early late
see like a gravey as the greeter that's
someone with defensive button syndrome
yeah you know just i just
was never able to retire yeah and just
just here for for the quick benefits and
and out to get the early bird special
the early button special
i'm doing good i'm i'm doing good it's
been a whirlwind of of of uh intensity
lately we set up
a new office greg just moved we've had
so many things it's you know like it's
becoming summer now so like everything
is dropping
all at the same time
so uh you know it's been intense but
it's been good
how are you sir how are you sir
thank you thank you if it wouldn't
destroy everything right now i'd pan the
camera around so everyone could see the
whole room we got a bunch of standing
desks in here
we got she's got a bunch of start up now
yeah i know we got standing desks and
foam everywhere so you know
it's a pretty good corporate culture
that way uh the neighbors can't listen
in on the contest
like everybody else yeah yeah the
neighbors
they can't steal the content from us
they can't put a glass in their ear up
against the wall and like get the
spillover
yeah
oh someone miguel ledger says this
stream was more more gasmic that's
[ __ ] crazy
hell yes hell yes i want i actually
haven't seen the movie yet it's it's
hard to find people that are like no no
like i'm not kidding i actually want to
see more videos
time notwithstanding i would see morbius
with you thank you from belgium happy
happy my birthday to you jordan din
and uh thank you seth pollock i've never
been called a skinny legend before
which uh
which belgium are they from
oh that's a great question hey uh jordan
den which belgium are you from
and that's not karloff on the phone it's
my dude aaron electric night it's my
dude aaron warner you've seen him in a
few of our videos we used to do the dank
ass stubs podcast together
hey uh uh just arbitrary um if you get
100
in uh super chats in the next uh two
minutes we'll bring dave stuffs back all
right
all right 100 worth of super stickers in
the next two minutes as we end this live
stream dank s dubs will return it will
be resurrected thank you dcf and goodbye
for the happy birthday
uh jacob raymond there's no way john is
in his 40s
i mean there could be a way
but it is not this way
um yeah
yes and i am john not jerry thank you
for reminding yourself of that big joe
logan
big joe mogan
that's how you can tell like you got
some like
diehards man you got some committed you
got a committed audience like they were
they were with you before the name
changed i know that's how you can yeah
that's exactly how you can tell because
that was a very distinct moment in time
there was like a little bit of lag
between both of our names changing
reverting but yeah that's that's an era
that's one era to the next
aaron and jerry
aaron and jerry back in the day
that's right yeah yeah and we almost
jumped the shark but but we got it back
we we proved ourselves we got renewed
philly g
sorry philly g left a moment of
like silence transgender
where
where it's like no no no no you like i
was assigned male at birth i'm still a
boy but you did it wrong you made me the
wrong kind of boy
that's basically what you and greg did
yeah
pretty much
[Music]
it's a working it's always a an open tab
work in progress
yeah yeah i tried i tried to identify it
with jerry but you know it wasn't quite
right
tarz cooper thank you so much you're the
good kind of metaphorical anchor dear
john best of days to you and all the
rest as well thank you i appreciate that
very much we're gonna check the super
chats one more time
and then aaron and i are gonna
no more morbin
there's i mean there's a lot of morb
heads in the chat i've seen some morbius
i've seen some morbid time and some
morbia sweep in the chat tj perry thank
you so much for the super sticker get up
right is that what that says hold on i
gotta i gotta go in they make these
things really tiny get good
get good thank you so much i appreciate
the love
all right guys i think it's it's
oh dude we're gonna be so bloodborne by
the end of this it's it's my name day
we're doing it
happy birthday ooh sl7 says john solo
show on the channel he takes calls i
would love a show taking calls i think
that would be very fun i hope one day we
could just take a call line a request
line and thank you ddm pictures
yeah and i want a big green screen
behind me that features you know
oscillating uh nonsense graphics and
things like that and i want to hawk uh
questionable products to people
yeah
we gotta get some supplements
yes
yeah a john branded supplement would
make you just like chill out and take
your time
it would basically be like micro dosing
thc kind of yeah micro dosing thc or
like micro dosing a mushroom
yeah yeah i'm for that i'll be i'll put
my name i'll put my name on that i'll
co-sign that brand brand deal
that's right kids hugs and drugs lance
davis thank you so much to for reminding
us don't forget to smash the like button
and support john's birthday every like
my birthday gets happier so it's all on
you guys put the team on your back dude
you have to damage your device
yeah yeah yeah hit it with a hammer hit
the like button with a hammer
whether it's on your mouse or your track
pad whatever it might be um christopher
hyde wants to know are y'all hiring any
hype guys i can just sit in the corner
and say nice things towards y'all like
happy birthday you don't look a day over
45. you're already killing it
christopher hyde i appreciate that
you're killing it you are the hype guy
of the real rejects now
and uh you know
i don't know i don't know if she could
do the same type of hype guy but i feel
like with what you guys need are like
like
like old southern black church lady so
it's like
after like every goods like point that
you or greg makes it
[Music]
oh i want it i would feel so
uh authoritative with that kind of
backup
yeah i i can't remember where i heard it
but i maybe it was like on a maybe it
was on like a spill.com or a double
toasted but i know somebody was telling
the story of like
yeah i was uh i was like uh
you know defending my doctoral
dissertation and my mom
my mom said
telling baby because she
you know she just she just
learned how to be in like a large solemn
room from just being in like southern
churches her whole life ah
i mean you pick up a lot there and it's
got to stay in your mind that's that's
not a forgettable place to be
oh my goodness there are more heads in
the chat now i follow morbius like
deadheads follow the grateful dead says
lance davis hell yeah we got
when when morbies came back in those
thousand theaters they toured around the
country
that is what i'm talking about that's
what i want happy womb emancipation day
thank you balanced will thank you
christopher hyde for the vibe sticker
that's two dollars toward the return of
dick stops
uh ian hurst thank you so much and uh
morbius extended cut we do need that
mode man and thank you lone star friend
uh
some alan smithy says i'm 46 and my
balls are on the floor 45 is cool though
good excellent are you sitting on the
floor
are you sitting on your balls
are you seeing all your balls on the
floor are you balling
you know they make uh those those um
medicine balls that you can sit on so
you know why don't you just it's the
organic version of that
anyway guys i think we've hit the wall i
think we have we have it's 3 15 in the
afternoon
and we are in good company but i think
it's time to start wrapping this thing
up we got more work to do we got guests
coming over to shoot more stuff and we
got more equipment to assemble and all
sorts of things
so uh my dude do you have any parting
words for the people of the reject
nation
oh man
just every day
of my life
just
blessed up bless up you heard it here
folks i'm gonna
through more of all things are possible
morbius sweep uh yeah uh morbius
extended cut morbius um um you know
roadshow
uh morbius revival imac screening all
that stuff morbius 3d re-release
spin-off series all that
30 seconds to morbid 30 seconds to morbs
it's time oh we got one straggler super
sticker you are the last one kayla v
kayla v i'm gonna put you on the desk
really quick a-ron
uh kayla v thank you for the plum the
enamored with itself very pleased with
its visage plum i appreciate that love
uh and uh gonna do one quick just uh
tool through the chat once more just to
just to make sure we got everybody i
mean i'm not gonna get everybody it's
impossible it's a statistical
impossibility but yes uh michael legere
greg d disney fan louie berry
goo goo
goo moo i i got part of your name there
oh it's zonte you were too generous i'm
i'm gonna i gotta cut you guys off uh
420 dabs morbius mcdonald's toys we got
definitely need some morbius mcdonald's
toys mode man thank you so much bagel
trails thank you so much i'm glad you
had a good time and uh thank you for
sticking with me uh bagel trail says bye
to aaron as well there's some air in
love appreciate that reject nation stand
up
lance davis
sl7 all right guys morbius lunchbox
morbius coloring book all the morbins
all the timeses
uh gonna flash these super stickers up
on screen thank you louie berry thank
you so much uh
we might
get close
uh we're actually kind of close to this
uh to this goal that we uh arbitrarily
set up here
i mean it's like we we're at like 75
right now since uh since you said that
so
requiem for a morbius dream greg is out
on an appointment right now uh and he'll
be back in the room in a few um but
thank you guys for the birthday love
foreskin arun
and then this chaos reigns yes greetings
to argentina thank you so much for the
love rory sarah ladderer thank you uh
iron phoenix chase elliott louie berry i
know i've said a few of your names
multiple times uh but yeah christopher
hyde kayla v itzante thank you for these
lovely stickers and uh louie berry i'm
just gonna pull the chat over here so
they can see yours look at that look at
that that's beautiful
love it oh my goodness y'all are so
generous
um thanks for making this feel like a
really happy birthday thank you for
joining you know it's a monday afternoon
you know nobody you never know how many
people are going to be around on a
monday um but yeah seriously
morb nation solidarity all day every day
so yeah thank you guys for tuning in
leave a like if you can and uh yeah
follow the podcast
and uh keep an eye out for more fun
stuff we got tons and tons and tons
coming your way and more birthdays there
will be greg's birthday coming up in
september so you've got that to look
forward to
anyway uh happy320
go get dank
smoke a drug
and we will catch you on the next one
again thank you guys all so much for the
love for the super chats for your time
for your enthusiasm for your comments
and your thoughts and uh we'll see you
next time uh ending the stream now
it's hard to let go i don't want to but
more about
be well and as always cheers
[Music]
you know you hit the end stream button
and it always takes a little while so
this is the part where we [ __ ] talk
everybody for real just kidding any